morning
um okay so I can only assume we're
online but I I've actually actually
talked to Terry about getting the camera
have the red light so we know whether
the camera is on or not but um so
hopefully hope that'll hopefully no
there is no red light
evidently it's an extra so hopefully
we'll get that taken care of
okay what's our first whe this is oh the
the fun one right5 all
right okay so we have an amendment in
front of us
Keith
yeah and it's all how many
pages quite a few
all right 19 19
Pages um I we have this presentation
we'll explain section by section okay uh
I think we'll when don't we I guess um
the first question I have is there
anybody in the audience who um is
concerned or as problems or anything we
need to know up front about
645 okay good that's what that's what I
wanted to see I can introduce news is
good news all right so okay so we have a
presentation yeah and I have like some
opening remarks if you want yeah right
what's that represent
spe you couldn't hear me when you face
that way I couldn't tell what you were
saying what are we going to be doing
with 645 we uh the we will hope that we
will be passing this amendment we're not
going to talk about the new Amendment
first that that's what we're going to do
we're going to have a presentation on
what the new Amendment says okay well if
we haven't heard no no I was more
worried about anybody in the audience
who has uh had any concern with this
bill at the moment so that that we knew
ahead of time if there was going to be
problems but if that but they haven't
seen the
amendment uh but the am the amendment's
been floated around yeah so but we'll
find out they may not have seen it they
may not have seen it okay so they may
true okay
all right you're on Keith
okay uh thank you Mr chair uh so I'll
just give an opening high level overview
of what we're talking about here because
this is uh this is New Territory for uh
jurisdictions um this concept of a of a
DA uh utilizes
technology uh to allow for Collective
action okay so a lot of the concepts are
very old
um uh governance right so the state
itself uh is similar to a dow right so
people vote on their represent
representatives and then we sit on this
committee and we vote on proposals and
those proposals are called bills right
and our vote determines the outcome of
that
process um so what a dow does is utilize
technology to capture that in in a in a
a form where it's it's cryptographically
provable quick um would you mind moving
your mic closer contr here thank you
how's that thank you did you hear me so
far yeah thank you so what kind of tools
do you need well if you know how to use
a web
browser and you know how to install a
plugin if you know what a plugin is for
a web browser you pretty much have all
the tools you need to participate in a
dow and some of the newer web browsers
have this functionality built right into
it so it's not uh
it's not something very esoteric it's
becoming more easily uh usable so what
we could do if we if we wanted to I
could open my laptop I could create a I
could create a
dow and it would yeah I could right and
I could give each of us a a an
ID like an nft you probably heard the
term nft we could each have a way to
prove who we are and then we could
submit
proposals which could be a bill or
something like that and then the the
system would track our votes and
determine the outcome and it's all open
on a blockchain it's all publicly
viewable and and auditable and it's
immutable can't those those votes can't
be changed so that's just to give you
like a way to think about it um and so
this amendment is an attempt to give a
DA legal
personhood so there's Dows being created
this minute all over the internet all
the time some of those organizations
some of those Collective actions may
become the next Facebook Google meta
they may be become that big in the
future and so what this bill is trying
to do and other states are doing it
other states have done it is give a give
the ability for a DA group of people
acting collectively on the internet a
way to register with the state to have
conferred upon it some of the the same
things that llc's and corporations and
other other legal entities have so why
would the Dow want to do that uh number
one to limit their
liability so we have we have limited
liability here when we make decisions
we're protected by the state that we
can't be sued for our votes
right does that make sense so we're when
you confer limited liability onto a
corporation we're Frank franchising what
we have onto that entity that's
basically what we're doing and um the
reason why a dow might want to do it one
for limited liability so that they can't
be sued they can only lose their
investment just like you just like you
do with an LLC and then also to
interface with the legal system so Dows
can hire employees and they can give
those employees benefits and there are
other Dows that those DS can interact
with to provide those those services
this ecosystem is being built right now
on the internet so um that's you know
one reason is to interact with with the
legal system own a have a bank account
own own real
property and uh I invited someone to
come if we have time to have them speak
uh Kumar if you could just raise your
hand Kumar can talk to us about how
tokens can interact with uh with real
world assets so that's tokenization of
real world assets that's a separate but
related topic but a d can do that D can
own a token that represents a a real
world asset so um what this amendment
does and we're going to walk through
it is it takes definitions from model
law there's a a group called koala and
they're they're lawyers all around the
world working on this that's what we
started with that's what we heard back
in
February so then we've got input from
other stakeholders and we pulled in
existing statutes some of it from
existing LLC law to kind of round out uh
to kind of fit that model law into the
the current framework in in New
Hampshire so it's a detailed subject as
you can see by the stack of this
presentation but it's it's very
interesting and it's uh we're kind of at
the Forefront of uh a new way for people
to collectively Act
and also have some ownership over that
action so there's there's complaints
about corporations that only a few
people make the decisions only a few
people own the assets what a dow does is
allows lots of people to participate in
those decisions and and have a little
piece of of ownership so it's it's an
exciting
topic so any questions so far no it
sounds like he's your need can turn on
yeah sounds like he he's talking about a
Union I'm sure a union could use it yes
you could create a union with a do was
the
question it sounds like he's trying to
create a union or it sounds like a union
a union union yes you could I'm all
for I I I do have a question okay
yes I was going to recognize need an
next so okay represent thanks um
representative could you give us an
example
of a real life um um G that that's
operating right now just to kind of give
us a real real life example yeah so Dows
can be used for a lot of things so um
one of the first uses was uh something
called decentralized Finance so you've
probably heard of defi that's a new
fairly new term um but a
decentralized uh a defi system would be
uh A system that operates in computer
code that people can use to trade one
token for another so like one token that
represents an asset for another token
and you know it's sort of like how the
stock exchange works so that's that's
kind of an early example but there's
more recent examples where there's a dow
that is for the film industry so they're
crowd sourcing and crowdfunding the
development of new movies and they're
selling Advanced tickets to those movies
the ticket is an nft and when they make
the movie they you can use the nft to to
watch the movie or get special extra
features and that could replace
Hollywood at some point right so there's
it's possible right um so there's
there's you know there's a dow that is
funding um military equipment and food
and uh you know resources for victims in
the Ukraine so there's there's something
called the Ukraine D so that' be a
philanthropy D so there you know there's
uh many more examples happening it's
it's a experimentation and the cream
kind of Rises to the top right so a lot
of dows may not be
successful um but eventually you know
the best ideas rise to the top got
followup um can you give me one example
of scenario where it might be um a dow
I'm trying to phrase this um a dow would
be um dangerous either to security or to
an investor yeah uh so Define dangerous
right I'm be used to uh um um uh
subsidized terrorists or um that kind of
thing or somebody um loses their money
and and are not don't have a secure
investment like you know Mr Mr freed
who's who's going to jail for the rest
of his life yeah so that that wasn't a
dow okay actually there's a point that
uh if FTX had been a dow and registered
in a state that would have provided more
okay protections to the participants so
FTX is a centralized offshore system it
it dealt with digital tokens that's true
but it's not related okay so what about
funding terrorists for example uh with a
dow I mean if it was caught doing that
the in the bill the AG would uh
eliminate their legal protections okay
so I mean the idea is that now we
actually have a structure in the state
to go after them right
then so that's I to me that was one of
the reasons why we're doing this so
representative spear yeah okay you'll be
next I haven't seen the uh the latest
Amendment but I've gone over the old the
other the last previous amendment in a
great deal great deal of detail and it
it looks pretty pretty okay to me but
there were two things that I didn't
really quite figure out what was
happening the Dow was going to be
registered with uh
unh's uh iol
lab is that a contract that you see that
the state is going to have with UNH and
who pays for that because there's no
fiscal note with any of this so I don't
get the idea of how that relationship is
supposed to happen and I had a second
question after that yes I I can address
that so uh in in the original state
budget there was1 and A5 million dollar
for UNH to to develop blockchain
capabilities so that would have but the
Senate I haven't noticed the Senate
pulled it out oh so there may be other
funding for UNH but this amendment it
does reference UNH the interoperability
lab which is a great place to tour if
you want to go see um yeah if you're
computer geek it's a NE place oh so
you're not going to specify yeah so we
backed away just made it more generic
and there's uh the last page of the bill
talks about the Secretary of State
putting it out for an RFP we we may have
a few wrinkles to work out with that
exact process but and it could end up
being UNH interoperability lab but um
you know we'll we'll open it up to bid
that's the idea my second question or
maybe it's an opinion I don't
know so I looked at a bunch of other
Dows and one of the a dow that's like
out there that's kind of typical for
stable coins is
makerd
and they are actually develop they have
their own cryptocurrency they have
dieses and that one die equals a dollar
and all all that kind of stuff whatever
right but what I see in other
countries and I haven't looked at the
states and I have not so I'm lack on
that is the notion that a DA has to have
some in the legislation for the DA has
to have some notion of that the Dow has
to
implement anti-terrorism funding
techniques and which I think are K kyc
know your customer kind of thing and the
other one for anti
um money
laundering yes so those are still open
questions uh with a so we didn't do
anything with that yet no but all other
federal and state laws would still apply
to it now so it doesn't just like if you
created an LLC and you were financing
terrorism you uh you'd still be you know
responsible for that
yeah I do see it explicitly said like in
Switzerland and the UK and other places
so the our banking statutes if if a dow
was involved with
banking uh our banking statutes would
apply to the Dow if if it was in that in
that area of if so if you look at the
end of the so is it like being
Incorporated in I mean is it that you
choose the state that they're choosing
when you create this that you are going
to be uh administrated by this statute
by by the the right the laws of New
Hampshire because most corporations have
that on their documents they say I'm
sorry so most corporations you'll see in
the fine print you know all that stuff
they they you can't barely read but you
can it's in there it says at the end of
the day if you want to sue them where
what court what court you sue them under
in other words if there is a problem
they're being administered by exate
they'll have a state in most cases you
know Corporation at Delaware what I'm
concerned about specifically is is if we
don't say
something does that put the state
forgetting about the doubt does that put
the state in a liable St situation no
it's the state is this it just means
it's going to come to our state court so
if you if that's a liability that for
the state courts to have to handle the
case but at the end of the day then then
the person you know the two people who
are suing each other are going to be
paying for the their court case you it's
not the state it's not you know we're
not you know it's not it's not the uh I
don't think it's Attorney General's
office that's going to be pursuing the
case unless you know unless it was
clearly a class action suit or some kind
of suit that was related to the
Hampshire citizens but uh I'm worried
about it the feds go after us not
worried about somebody suing us oh yes
they do well feds would feds would go to
a federal court anyways yeah okay they
would ignore state
courts you feel comfortable with it
that's fine with me yeah no I I'm very
excited about
this so I just want to point you to page
18 line
22 on which version on the the one that
you have printed out in front of you I
think the one that was handed
out so it's um just I should it's
amendment number unapproved amendment
number 2327
H so page
18 line
22 in the
amendment all right that's
helpful that's helpful
so just read it real quick application
of other laws for avoidance of any doubt
in New Hampshire D shall be subject to
all other applicable laws of the State
of New Hampshire including laws
regulating Securities activities Banking
and Financial activities Taxation and
all other provisions of law
so right that's one of the improvements
that we made that was one of the
Herbert you need to turn your microphone
on and pull nice and my first question
is um I have trouble with the English
decentralized a Dao is a decentralized
autonomous
organization so um I'd like to know what
autonomous means in in in this
particular uh
usage and decentralized I would like to
know what that means to the pro you know
promoters
and um is there a political ideology
involved here what's the
philosophy right democracy because to me
decentralized autonomous is almost a an
oxymoron not to me I mean okay so I'm
going to be the the the neite in the
room on this one okay okay all right
autonomous is uh any Corporation any
entity is autonomous it has it
Standalone it's autonomous by itself yep
so decentralized is saying is that like
when we think of most corporations well
you got to start with the top who's the
chairman of the board or who's the CEO
and decentralized means no we don't have
that corporate structure it's
decentralized so that every member of
this Dow is equal there is no CEO
there's no one person so that's what
that decentralized autonomous means to
me that that can be one version there's
some definitions in the bill that that
might be helpful on page two line 20 is
decentralized autonomous organization so
that's the beginning of a definition but
uh the real meat of it is on page three
line 18 it talks about a decentralized
governance system and that that has some
thresholds built in it so that one
person can't control have an outsize
controlling stake of the organization so
I'll just want to make one one uh Nuance
okay you mentioned maker so maker has a
stable coin which is a token that
represents a dollar and they they manage
it so that one die is worth $ one dollar
constantly it doesn't fluctuate like
other but they also have a governance
token and what we're talking about is
the governance token right so the
governance token gives you rights over
what decisions that organization makes
and so when you look at page three line
decentralized governance system that's
really the the token that gives people
the ability to to collectively make
decisions if that makes
sense representative Burrows yeah I just
I have a concern which is that I mean
this is a complicated thing it's a
19-page document which we just got
yesterday I don't know about anybody
else I got back from California I didn't
even see this till this morning
and we haven't had a chance to discuss
it people who read it and well we're not
we're not executing this bill no I know
but it and the bill came out according
to this on the 10th of October so it
would have been nice we're not going to
ex I understand that but it would have
been nice if we had had an opportunity
to go through it this was available
yesterday afternoon about 4:30 I know
and I didn't see this is a work session
so we're not I understand Kei but it
would have been nice if we gotten it
before we could dis all discuss it with
some intelligence it wasn't possible I'm
sorry so what we will do is we will have
another subcommittee when if if we're
November so if we're still aiming for
the November 7th exact session which we
don't have to right because we have
another week after that right don't we
so we do but it I would certainly say we
can set up for the exact session to be
in the afternoon and then have uh the
the subcomittee uh in the day before or
in the morning and and which time if the
if concerns have are coming forward we
will know it I mean I I mean at the end
of the day you we don't have to pass
this this year if you really want a wait
a year simply because you you know
there's so many pages here that's fine
we can we can be patient you know uh you
know Rome wasn't built in a day okay so
so I I sorry that we're just getting
this now um but that yes we can that I
will absolutely give plenty of time to
for everybody to thrash it out and since
I will be out of out of country next
week you have a whole time to stir up
all the trouble you want in figuring out
what you want to do with this and then
when we get I get back we can then see
where we're at at that time okay so I I
I'm sorry that you feel that this is
being just well I me frankly we get a
lot of things like this the day before
it's happened before so that's my
concern so if I can interject Mr ch um
we we do have a presentation that we
could go through um and it would explain
a lot of the questions that people are
asking represent M um just I still don't
quite understand how this is structured
and how it functions and Keith you said
you uh representative um let's say you
you formed a a business or a doop with
all of us um and you're you're going to
make
widgets do we invest money to be a
member of
this so the answer is it depends right
so the governance tokens that give you
the ability to make decisions that they
can be given away freely if you want if
you wanted to do that or it could be a
membership based thing where you pay you
know dues and and if if somebody has
more tokens than another person do they
have more say you seem to say that it
was uh that was probably not the case
but if I'm I'm relating it to a
shareholder yeah a shareholder who's got
more shares has more say does that work
here so again it depends it would be how
the dial is structured so you could have
a token based voting system or the more
tokens just like the more shares gives
you more votes or you could have like a
non-transferable nft where it's like a
digital ID just for you and then each
person would have the same number of
votes so depend on how the dial got
structured a quick followup then but you
got to come up with the money to start
your widget Factory where does that come
from uh just so that would be like real
world things you know things happening
in the real world so just like any
company you need Capital to to do that
right so you vestures at that level but
a dow doesn't need to inter a dow can
interface with the real world it doesn't
have to depending on what its goals and
purposes so it's all in their bylaws
right okay all right so um I assume that
you want to see Bill AR's
Bill
good morning uh Mr chairman members of
the committee my name is Bill ardinger
I'm an attorney at a local Law Firm
wrath young and Pignatelli um I'm here
in my personal
capacity uh and and not as a lobbyist on
behalf of any client I am at times a
lobbyist who's registered on behalf of
clients um but in this case I am
performing this uh presentation in my
capacity is Bill ardinger who was uh the
chairperson of Governor sununu's
commission to study digital assets and
cryptocurrency which issued its final
report in December of last year and one
of its
recommendations was that New Hampshire
should enact a legal entity law for
these decentralized autonomous
organizations and you have before you
something that came over the email to
the committee but also printed out this
morning a PowerPoint presentation from
that I have prepared working with
representative Ammon that provides a
section by section summary of the
amendment that you also have before you
um and uh but before I really go into
that I want to take one deep breath back
to
the reason for this important
bill um things are changing out there
the commission concluded that um these
structures blockchain which is a type of
software used across the internet the
internet itself is relatively new from
the 60s forward my friend there from
digital was working with early stages
from when we testified on this bill in
in the spring um and right now the
choice for
lawmakers is whether to
allow those developments to go on
without adequate legal
infrastructure to support them or to
provide a balanced thoughtful
precedent-based
legal structure that will try to
encourage and provide stability to these
organizations that they go forward
representative spear asked the most
important question which is hey if we
create this legal
structure are we
facilitating uh and represent bur crime
terrorism bad things
and my answer would be directly the
opposite and this is what the commission
found after studying for seven eight
months is
that there's a divide that we're
suffering right now there's the
technically proficient World which is
very fastel with software with the
internet with these structures and then
there's the legal system which is
backward it is not yet upgraded this is
an old story I'm looking at
representative hunt
in in I've worked with you many ye many
years over the years with um situations
where developments in our economy our
private economy were moving so fast that
our laws got stale and then incomes
lobbyists for Industries and
stakeholders working with agencies to
try to upgrade those laws and legal
systems we've done that New Hampshire
did with corporate law through the 1800s
and that took a long time but
ultimately the innovation in the legal
system of providing legal
personhood to these corporate entities
along with limited liability for
shareholders which is when you invest
your money $1,000 for stock your house
doesn't also get exposed to law losses
that Innovation started in a General
Corporate Way in New York state in 1811
it created some Scholars
argue the force and power of the growth
of the United States economy to the
point where we became a leader in the
world we've done this with
llc's we've done this with statutory
Investment Trust we've done this with
cooperatives they never had a legal
system until the legislature took it
upon themselves to upgrade their laws to
provide this in this case before you you
have a situation where there's a
community out there in the world who say
there's no laws governing me we're new
we're on the internet we're software
therefore we don't have to comply with
the Securities laws we don't have to
comply with kyc we don't have to comply
with other requirements this exists but
when when states are proactive and start
recognizing this economic activity with
sound legal
structures the answer becomes
representative spear that section that
Keith just quoted that was a an
improvement that happened since the
original presentation of the bill it is
because there are stakeholders who are
not just technically proficient people
they're aate agencies that care a lot
about the jobs that they have and they
many of them had served on the
commission with Keith and me and others
so with that background I would just say
that the presentation goes through
Section by section what this bill does
in summary what this bill does is pick
and choose Provisions that this
legislature has already adopted some of
them I've had a hand in drafting over
the years as a lobbyist things like
statutory invest M trust I testified in
front of this commission years ago we
needed it why because it was going to
bring to this state Economic Development
sound and jobs from the mutual fund
industry and it did I also sat in front
of this commission to urge uh this
committee to urge modernization of trust
laws representative hunt suffered
through those presentations that bill
was four times as long as this one but
it has had a modernization effect that
has been beneficial not only to industry
but also to people who want to do things
like established trust for their pets
this is modernization and I stand before
you sit before you today to say what
this bill does is by looking at preceden
in our law it recognizes the
uniquness of this activity which is it's
happening not in a way that appoints
directors and appoint a CEO with a
centralized corporate structure other
states are making that mistake as they
try to upgrade their legal Plumbing to
provide uh and support sound development
in this industry this bill recognizes
that the newness of these entities is
that it's
happening in interactively among
decentralized computers all over the
internet without an active internet
these organizations couldn't be there in
this way that is because of the internet
this is a progressive use of the
internet to provide potentially a
structure that can make innovations that
are really important to humans May these
organizations perform activities that
are not good for society just like
corporations but if you make clear that
your laws that are sound and that they
apply
to these organizations perhaps you will
be part of the innovations that like New
York started in 1911 in 1811 with
corporations that ended up with Delaware
having you know a significant part of
their State's economy operating on sound
legal entity laws is it boring yes is it
nerdy yes but it's really important the
plumbing in your bathroom the granite of
your countertop the fixtures are
beautiful and they're fun to look at but
guess what they don't work without
plumbing and that's what this bill is
part of so I won't go any further other
than to say as a chair of the commission
who spent nine months working with
experts and others and agencies I
believe this is important for the state
to take a lead role in another change
I'll close with representative spear in
this bill is with discussions with
stakeholders the effective date of most
of the operative sections of this bill
is now set for January 1 2025 under the
amendment before you it the only section
that becomes effective immediately is
the one that instructs the Secretary of
State's office to develop procedures and
protocols uh for how this unique
registry would work and who would
operate it as a registration Authority I
will last say that the unit UNH
interoperability lab is a gem
in this state they are used by every
structure in the world's internet
economy to test how their software
interacts with others on the internet if
this legislature and it almost did the
governor was very supportive of it it
didn't happen because we have to have
priorities in the budget I was a
legislator in 1980 and 81 for cornish
and cuden I know those prioritizations
are tough but we have the possibility in
New Hampshire I believe with with the
combination of uh Innovative legislation
like
this with Incredible knowledge of a
governmental organization like UNH
interoperability lab just giving it a
little bit of help we could be the
leaders in bringing these structures
into the modern economy and I think we'd
benefit as a state our families our
economy would thank you for I'm sorry I
didn't walk through the PowerPoint but
it's there in front of members to look
at
especially since we obviously want to
take some time to go through this yes
anyways so yes representative
burrow thanks for that great
presentation I really you really made it
um easy to follow I appreciate that um
because I'm not a nerd well I am but not
not specifically in terms of this so um
if there was let's say a hypothetical
there's a large corporation in New
Hampshire could they morph into this
this um this structure to govern that's
a great question and it focuses on in my
view the real distinction here
corporations are by their very nature
structures that use Central authorities
to make decision in this bill there are
definition definitions in order to
qualify for the registry the New
Hampshire registry which would be the
first in the in the country this kind of
registry it you have to have a
decentralized governance system and a DE
centralized um structure what that means
is no one force person group May
unilaterally change the rights of every
other participant and it's it they're
based on definitions in federal
legislation so in my view a corporation
which is a centralized by its nature
would never be able to convert to this
because to do so they'd have to fire
their CEO they'd have to fire their CFO
they'd have to adopt a c calization
structure that may have real legal
agents in the world the the the physical
world like a DA could appoint me to
accept service of process if someone
wanted to sue it which right now doesn't
exist it's and it's a very mess at the
federal level there are cases unraveling
which this kind of thing would solve but
they're everyone struggling with the
uncertainty so no representative I don't
believe a corporation would be able to
morph into this unless it wanted to give
up its fundamental corporate
structure um so do you see this as a
viable option for a new company forming
to go with this structure I I
do uh I am a tax nerd and I'm 63 years
old I am not as technically proficient
as I would like to be there is something
out there in our economy that is
building off of the incred incredible
innovation of the internet that is
allowing uh cross
jurisdictional
collaborations to happen in ways that
they never did in the 80s when I was a
young lawyer right so I think the answer
is this is coming there will be younger
people than me who will see the benefits
of this I already just met a a friend
that that Keith brought in who's working
in this space and and uh he who is
technically proficient sees the benefits
of this um I think that this could be
something that
creates uh organizations that are
incredibly Bene beneficial to people all
over the world not necessarily limited
to a particular jurisdiction but rather
I can imagine at one use of blockchain
that was cited as a very positive
development from a witness who was very
skeptical of some of the current
structures like FTX which is under
indictment you know bankruptcy now is is
is she said this structure can be used
to efficiently allow people who are
doing well in an economy like the United
States legally to transfer dollars to
their families in other right now the
International System takes gigantic fees
on those International transfers this
could be rolled out in a way that is not
that is you know going to be a real
Innovation that helps families worldwide
not you know so we have not yet seen all
of the creativity of these uses but by
upgrading the legal
Plumbing
hopefully new remember in this case
right now Dows don't have to register
publicly anywhere their code actually is
online it is accessible but the
governmental status of the entity is
uncertain this requires in order to get
the benefits of the statute just like
corporations you have to register with
the New Hampshire Secretary of State
just like in other entity so that
transparency you have to in order to
qualify for this you have to post your
code you have to post written bylaws
that a lay
person can understand we all know bylaws
are hard to so yes I think I think this
could be the basis for something
positive and with good agencies like we
have in this state Dr Securities banking
AG consumer
protection I'm hopeful that the
development will happen in a way that is
helpful to people and they will help
ensure in all in addition to the
transparency and openness that's
required ensure that negative stuff is
minimized so you're saying I'm not going
to be alive to see this because I'm
older than you uh I think representative
Burrows you and I are going to be alowed
to see this I don't know that we will be
the leaders who will be implementing
this with code on the internet because I
think we'd have to learn a lot before we
got there unless you have a lot of free
time yeah representative
mcair
um thank you uh you're obviously very uh
knowledgeable about this stuff and I my
question is you do you see any if you
looked into the future do you see any
shortcomings that this um potentially
doesn't address I mean again things are
going extremely fast we're just catching
up but is there is there something
missing or something that that is is
going to happen in the future that uh uh
we're going to have to catch up some
more on the answer
is is number one yes but I'm going to
tell you why it's a good thing that we
pass this bill the LLC didn't exist in
the United States until the late 70s
Wyoming was a leader New Hampshire
didn't adopt the LLC law until the early
90s um I was part of that adoption has
the LLC law in New Hampshire been
amended many times since it was
originally conceived in the first
Statute in Wyoming that was adopted yes
sir are those amendments bad or
indicative that the original bill should
not have been enacted absolutely not it
was with out without that original
initiative to say and signal to the
world that we are intending to be uh
establish a legal stable environment for
this development we would not have had
the benefits that LLC law has provided
but yes sir there's going to be
amendments to this bill and to others
across the country for years to come it
will not settle the developments will
but we will at least catch up a little
bit with what's going on in the world
thank you representative
Herbert
um I'm in
politics so I'm right here we're doing
politics and I I have yet to understand
exactly the
philosophy that is generating all of
this I can
understand that technology is going
always has been going so fast I mean AI
is all the rage and uh uh but but you
need a philosophy a political philosophy
in order to have me or and I think most
people be
comfortable uh in what you're trying to
do now when when I said autonomous
autonomous means you regulate
yourself decentralized means that I I am
deregulated I am
autonomous I have a problem with that
concept because it sounds exactly like a
Libertarian philosophy and I have a
problem with Libertarians so that I'm
this is a political argument so when I
asked you or I don't know I don't know
if I asked you but my question was
somebody please give me the
philosophy behind it now you're giving
me a little taste of it
in the sense that uh I can see where in
the speed of the world now um I'm not
sure that having everybody do their own
thing uh is the right way to go I
actually you know armies are centralized
corporations are
hierarchical okay and now you're talking
flat land and I'm going gez I'm not
quite
sure uh that this philosophy is going to
work right everybody's doing their own
thing and then you come in and say well
no the laws here will be adhered to okay
autonomous okay you can be an
independent but you have laws around you
to protect us and that's
politics and so I'm coming at it from
that point of view I need to be
persuaded that uh this is a what the
philosophy behind all this is and and so
I can understand where we might be
headed representative Herbert I
appreciate your question I can imagine
uh a a libertarian view saying you know
I don't need laws about private property
I don't need laws regulating private
property in the in a in a caricature
sense I don't think this is accurate and
and what you answer back is without laws
about filing a piece of paper with the
registry of deeds in counties
nobody has clear private property
without a legal
system you don't have the things that we
hold dear in this country these private
rules I would say to you uh
representative the corporate law
does not have a political philosophy it
is it is something that enables
individuals to come together there are
corporations whose leaders are very
strong uh Progressive registered
Democrats there are leaders of
Corporations who are very strong uh free
market
Republicans it is not the legal
infrastructure that enables and
clarifies the legal status of that
corporation that comes at it from one
way or another in this case having sat
for nine months on the commission and
learned about this what I found is that
you have political personalities from
all across the Spectrum just like every
human endeavor who are taking advantage
of these Technologies to deliver
services and products and opportunities
to individuals who want to come together
for that stated purpose the only problem
now is that when they come together
nobody knows what the consequences are
legally so the this law is not tilting
one way or another I would submit uh
respectfully representative that your
reading of autonomous as unregulated in
this bill is absolutely wrong it's not
this creates a transparent legal system
like the corporate law like the LLC law
like the statutory Investment Trust law
like the Cooperative law like the trust
law that says New Hampshire state laws
are modern and they facilitate sound
Economic Development and growth for the
benefit hopefully of people who live in
this jurisdiction and I think that it is
these this is not political this is
about a balanced legal structure that
can be used by human beings trying to
achieve their goals like the American
dream sounds great and uh I need the
details and I think I would urge you you
have had a chance if you take sorry
sorry
sorry you have to know is that he has in
the past voted against all
blockchain I I'm sorry I'm sorry if I
had my good friends here who are I've
worked it three years from the lobbing
group they would have been slapping me
in the back of the head with that
knowledge but I care deeply about your
comment I I think you you actually hit
the nail on the head when you say it is
RA really re when it comes to a
Libertarian yeah this is
anti-libertarian
because Libertarians would say is they
don't want any laws they wanted to be
the wild west out there they wanted to
be a freefor all so what's decentralized
mean
let's Okay so let's let's just say that
these
words these are just words okay and
sometimes when I read a bill and they
have and have these other references and
I have no idea where they're coming from
with us it do so I would say is forget
about the title forget about these words
think in your mind what we're about to
do here is very similar to the LLC
statute which was we are now in creating
a new incorporation
vehicle that is different okay it is
definitely different than in the other
incorporation vehicle that we've had
right we start out with s corpse you
know or B Corps and then s Corps and we
even have B corporations you know which
are promoting to suppos to be um
politically correct and you know doing
you know sound environmental things is a
Bor believe it or not so we we passed
that in the Hampshire okay so this in
llc's all of that is every we have
different structure so in this room we
have the Secretary of State we have our
Corporation division here okay and
they're saying is that that no
libertarian would ever intentionally
want to be registered with
them okay we are forcing them to be
registered and by we're doing it by the
forces is we are attracting to them to
have this structure to give them that
Integrity wherever business is doing it
so that they are not criminally involved
criminals don't like laws right
criminals if you want to do a criminal
activity you would not want to be in
thisor crypto do some washing but this
is not crypto well okay is a lot of the
langu language I understand the
blockchain concept makes it feel that
way but at the end of the day the most
important thing is is that you have to
register with the
state well I heard that okay that's that
takes that takes all exactly all the
other stuff that you your fear of
blockchain is that we now you have to be
known you have to have there's bylaws
that are up on the web you have to have
all your rules and regulations and what
you're doing has to be public
information representative spe is
next so and this is for Anita's benefit
I guess uh I spent a lot of time over
the summer going through this in
excruciating
detail and the dowo community and crypto
Community is a little bit like the wild
west right now and the idea that we have
some really thought through thought out
laws and uh
registration Tech uh this whole thing
the whole the bill I think is a terrific
idea because
it it's going to H whether we want it to
or not D exist
and by the way I found dozens of
different kind of dows on the internet
Dows that rent apartments Dows that buy
land dials that buy art dials that
create art uh dials that create money uh
cryptocurrencies Dows that exchange uh
stock uh portfolios all kinds of things
and if we don't get some laws around
this
stuff and make it so that it's
controllable to the extent that we're
not taking advantage of constantly and
investors can actually invest in these
things and not end up like uh FTX and
Sam bankman freed and lose eight billion
dollar overnight we have to have this we
have no choice we have to do this the
technology is moving whether we like it
or not so we get to get our heads around
it and it is a little complex but it's
not that bad it really isn't that bad
and hey you know I know I do read
automobile manuals for
fun so for me this is really not any as
bad as
that so look at it as a good thing thank
you representative spear okay
representative collabro very quickly I
just wanted to clarify something here
the beginning of Representative
Herbert's statement he said we're
politicians I take umbran with that I am
a public servant I'm not here for
political party and I don't sit here and
work behind the scenes with everybody on
this committee as a political entity I
need to clarify that thank
you would you believe I don't know it's
it's not a bad word in my okay any more
questions thank you very much Phil and
we'll look forward to seeing you again
thank you all for addressing this nerdy
topic but but it's important thank you
okay and are we're ready to move on and
we're not going to take any action and
we about security can be here oh sure
absolutely Securities and attorney you
Secretary of State's office you guys
want to come up and tell
Bill thank you Mr chairman Aaron
Hennessy deputy secretary of state uh
and Tom Conley director of
Corporations our security director could
not be here today but uh we are happy to
answer any questions you have I haven't
had a chance to read through the new
Amendment but I did read through and we
spent a lot of time in our department
discussing the um previous amendment to
this one so we are happy to work with
the committee um if you think we are the
the best um um Department to organize
this and I think it does make a lot of
sense um we would be happy to do that I
did um speak with the sponsor about the
fiscal impact to our department and that
there might be a fiscal impact um we
would need to have some uh expertise in
this area to help us out to especially
create the RFP for this uh I can see um
us creating a blockchain registry for
this which would also be um some I
believe something first the nation to
create a blockchain registry for the
purpose of blockchain or Dao um
companies um anything else you want to
add um no other
the okay better go um uh the in terms of
the the new the new uh section that was
added I'm sorry Tom Connelly with uh
director of Corporations uh at Secretary
of State's office how long have you been
director of Corporations um I've been
director for uh these last four years
and also served previously in that job
for for four years
okay um yeah the uh in terms of the the
the the new uh duties that have been um
added in the the current the new
Amendment are certainly things that this
office certainly has um the ability to
do certainly say we we need some to
bring in some some expertise certainly
from the technology side but um our
ability to find out exactly and analyze
what other jurisdictions are doing Sly
been following this very closely uh in
the various uh developments with regard
to Doos around the country I know that
uh let say Utah's law will go into
effect in January and they're currently
building a a process to to be able to
register Dows I know Virginia has been
working on this as well and I said so I
think we're You Know It uh we can't we
can't move too quickly in terms of being
able to be able to um provide a a
structure here that's uh going to be um
helpful in terms of uh be able to to
identify these these these entities we
first started with the original Bill
there was there really wasn't any en any
structure entity structure there in
terms of the fact that um we creating a
new um business registry but again on on
a blockchain um concept is very exciting
to to us certainly and uh the um the
fact that we'll have a place where when
someone wants to create a dow they'll
start out by first inting their intent
to do so but filing with a notice with
us at the Secretary of State's office
we'll Ure they have a registered agent
for service of process um and then they
move forward with the accreditation
authority to to meet all the
requirements of the Dow so I think
that's a very uh interesting concept
certainly should be should be certainly
workable for
us okay questions
from
Herbert u i I need to to see like you
said the llc's only came around out of
Wyoming of all places but apparently
Wyoming is uh into this and um I'm not
uh at all comfortable at this point with
the uh Concepts here they sound good uh
or in a vague way i' still I've still
don't I mean the Providence of
cryptocurrency was
crime so uh that's that's I'm I'm I am I
uh is who what does this come from you
know why is there suddenly this
huge uh push in order to rewrite our
laws
decentralized which has a connotation
for me and autonomous also has a
connotation for me and um and
libertarian fits I see red flags go up
everywhere
now how long do you
think it will take in order to because
this has been two years and they're
working really hard trying to get things
together how long would it take to make
me
comfortable that there is some control
here that there is this is not this is
not something you that uh um you know
the government has a responsibility to
the citizens I don't want to put them in
danger I sounds good what's a token a
token was a ticket a ticket we already
have now a token goes through the
internet and maybe it make becomes real
fast and doesn't cost as much and I'm
I'm okay with that but
um I I know I just know from
experience that the ones
that go like like that and say man I
know what I can do with
this are not are not honest people and
that's why I I'm very worried
that I'm I'm not at all satisfied at
this point and I'm just trying to get
something from you when are you going to
be able to satisfy me then is this no
this is it's going to take a while
because this is this is complicated
stuff um yes I can just like said I
don't not sure that I can I can be I'll
be the that will satisfy your con
concerns but um one of the thing that
that we find attractive about the about
the the bill is that for example anyone
who's going to create it out number one
is going to create file an intent to do
so so our Bureau of security is going to
know from the get-go when someone is
creating a dow they can look at the
structure they can see the bylaws they
can see the process if they are if they
fall into the definitional Securities
they're going to have to register
they're going to have to be regulated so
from that perspective I think we feel
pretty comfortable that it won't be
$1,000 form the first year it's going to
be a small growing process but it will
allow our our our infrastructure to be
able to identify these folks see how
they're organized and then be able to
follow through to make sure they're
following the banking laws the
Securities laws insurance laws whatever
is applicable
um the one thing too about about these
entities which which um I also find very
rep positive from a consumer point of
view is that right now if you form an
LLC after you form the LLC the only
information you have to give us is the
name of one of your members or or a
manager we don't know who all the owners
of the LLC are we don't know what their
operating agreement is we don't have any
information about there's no
transparency there with a DA everything
is completely transparent if we to see
the process that decisions are being
made by by The Entity as well as if they
appoint any administrators the names of
those persons are going to be on the web
we're going to know exactly who the
people are that are behind the the the
uh the Dow in terms of taking any
actions on their behalf so there's a
great deal of transparency that makes it
available to Consumers whether they're
members of the Dow or not which we also
think is pretty attractive for because
view representative Spear and then
represent just just a quick comment
there's a difference between a DA and
these laws the Dows are out there
whether we like it or not or or don't
like it or do like it or whatever
they're out there this is just to her
them in and to control what
access we as investors have to be able
to understand what's going on with the
Dow but these laws don't create
Dows these these laws allow us to
control the Dow and to have transparency
with the Dow so there's a difference and
and Dows are out there you're not going
to stop it they're happening because
they are legal in the United
States good point representative thank
you do you see any element of the Dows
security thank you for the question
representative I I think it's it depends
on what kind of um Dow that it is I'm
sure there are some Dows out there that
do sell Securities but there's others
that may be like a a Condominium
Association um where they just vote on
um things that happen with their
Association so it depends on what the
Dow is set up to do it's just like any
company so so not only might they have
to file Dow um information they might
have to uh actually uh file for as a
security correct in some instances yes
and I think that um representative said
on page 18 line 22 that this would not
prevent them from or this would not this
would still they would still have to
follow all other appical state laws
thank you can't skirt it okay so I was
going to be done but I uh uh urged me to
have Kamar you know Baka come on up and
and give us a give us a story or two you
know tell us tell
put some put some meat on one of these
bones for us so we have an idea what
we're talking
about my name is Kumar buap pattinam um
of Manchester New Hampshire my
background is in mathematics and
cryptography and I work in the asset
tokenization
space of I would like to clarify while
we have been calling these organizations
Dows a better rhetorical term from the
comments I've heard would be an
algorithmically governed Corporation
because that is what it is instead of
having let's say a a CEO or a board of
directors make corporate decisions we
have an algorithm
that controls the corporation controls
what it does and what this bill would in
effect do by creating a registry of
these
algorithms is provide sound legal
structure
for
this new form of corporate governance
that has made its way to the stand I
mean the primary reason why I'm in favor
of this bill in addition to all the
reasons spoken about is that fraud
actually will decline quite a bit if I'm
pitching a dow to my investors or
clients I can open up the Secretary of
State's website and say outright this is
the algorithm this is how this
investment or this firm is
governed
and there is absolutely no way
that any investor can hide manipulate
hide
and engage in Acts of fraud that they
actually would be able to under
traditional corporate governance as
we've seen with FTX and s bank and freed
in addition this bill would also greatly
encourage shareholder participation
corporate voting at best is very
difficult and at worst Byzantine which
leads to most of us even in our
investments throwing our vote away to
proxies by
allowing by allowing a cryptographically
secure corporate voting method we can
directly interact with our Corporation
and we can express our opinions without
a chilling effect because algorithms are
not susceptible to power plays and
conflict
are and
in and finally if anything this bill
would similar to New Hampshire's trust
laws bring a lot of domestic and forign
wealth to the state which is why I'm
here testifying in favor of this Bill
thank you very much for your time and
I'm open to answer any
questions any
questions represent Senor Herbert has a
question
algorithms um are your your
uh your expertise as a mathematician I'm
assuming that you've actually written
algorithms uh and and know all about
them yes now the idea is my concern one
of my concerns is that um nothing is
perfect and the first people to find out
where a weakness
is are usually going to do something
illegal now that's just
history uh and and and you so I'm I need
to know that these
algorithms uh I mean I've heard you know
somebody losing an algorithm and the
money is gone and they were some guy
went into a dump in uh in England I mean
it was just outrageous but I need to be
uh you know I am not secure yet with uh
this push and uh and do algorithms ever
make mistakes I mean is uh to aay your
concerns I would say that algorithms are
in no means perfect but they are a lot
better at managing than humans because
we are prone to error and more arguably
more so than
computers and to your point of let's say
losing your key it is a lot more
difficult to let's say lose a key than
lose that much of cash stuffed under
your mattress in that sense algorithms
are much more secure and even when they
fail because algorithms do fail in the
in a similar manner that humans do they
fail predictably which
makes the legal recognition of dows or
as I would say algorithmically governed
to necessary to encourage corporate
Innovation okay just one follow on
follow so
um if you're helping uh the state of New
Hampshire write these laws and
everybody's learning more and more about
them um does this mean that we need to
have somebody
with your kind of skill
set at you know we just talked to the
corporate division of the state do we
need to have somebody with your skill
set
uh as you know a full-time employee I
mean I'd be a lot more uh comfortable if
there was that kind of
expertise in the uh in in our
governance what this bill does is all it
does is to the representatives point the
algorithms are out there this bill just
puts them in a
registry similar to how a limited
liability Corporation operates I'd argue
that the skill set that is necessary is
the exact same as an
LLC the only difference is these
corporations are being run by an
people
what time is it now okay represent
Ammon thank you for coming I I do want
to make one point of clarification and
uh Kumar uh you haven't had any input in
this legislation is that correct yes so
there's no input but we're open to
suggestions from you so I want to make
that clear um so this is this is how I
Envision the transparency aspect right
so we all imagine xay glasses you know
that they sell them in the back of
magazines you put the xray glasses on
right
uh so a dow is sort of like x-ray vision
on how a corporation a corporation under
the structure operates you can see all
the decisions and the logic behind those
decisions like to a fine granular uh
level uh would you agree with that
assessment
yes what ad Dow effectively does is by
making the algorithms public investors
clients everyone can see exactly what is
going on bringing far more transparency
structures great thank you very much
okay I think we'll we'll stop this now
and uh we will take it up when we
schedule our next subcommittee and I
think we talking about
what it was November what was the
November 7th what day of the week was
that
okay so November 7th we'll we'll take
this up
again all right let's move on to the
next
bill
pasas okay representative spear you're
on
yeah
um
okay when last we
met in a place far far away and long ago
we had two bills hp2 42 and HP
465 those two bills
465 prohibited the sale of carpets with
pasas and 242 prohibited the sale of
pasas neither Bill required that the
state test anything it was going to be a
some notion of a clearing house and
vendors would have to put certifications
into their Clearing House swearing that
they don't have any PS in those uh those
um components products and if they did
then they could sell them in the state
of New Hampshire and if they did not
they would not be able to sell them in
the state of New
Hampshire one of the things that got me
really bothered by this not by the bills
but how I got into this past thing was I
the discovery materials from lawsuits
that happened to uh Dupont and
3M for 30 or 40
years Dupont and 3M
knew that they were poisoning their
employees as a matter of fact one of the
cases that settled in
1998 required Dupont to publish the
results of their findings
in the real world you would not be
allowed to do that kind of an experiment
on any set of
people they published information that
said there was no impact when they fig
figured out when they were required by
law to publish the results they found
out that pasas was causing testiscle
cancer uh liver
cancer kidney cancer
can and children born with disabilities
and low birth
weight when they found out that the
women who were working in those
facilities were being impacted they
transferred them as soon as they got
pregnant they transferred them out of
the
facility a reputable
company in my mind a reputable company
would never have done that but be that
as it
may then came the FDA and the FDA
says the FDA
says they don't test anything right in
this particular case I don't know if
they test anything in any other uh
industry but they don't test in the
chemical industry relating to past what
they do is they get letters and reports
from companies that say our components
are safe and the only thing you worry
about are bip are uh breakdown products
safe FDA published two two reports last
earlier this year actually this year but
earlier this year in which they said
that chemical companies were giving them
affidavits that said this stuff was safe
when in fact in the public research had
already proven they were not safe and so
the we couldn't count on the FDA anymore
EPA steps in and they start saying
things about the water and they put
limits on the water uh the
infrastructure bill has now some money
in it to try and clean up some of the
stuff 3M in their lawsuit they settle
for 12 billion now to me being a jaded
New Yorker anybody who's willing to
settle for 12 billion do without going
to court has something to hide but
me so all of that money is going to be
used to try and clean this up but P
cleaning up PS is very very difficult
okay so the only way we're going to stop
this is by getting it out of the stream
to begin with is to not letting it come
in now we have 3M and we have Dupont and
we have Honeywell and they are all part
of the pest manufacturing
industry but there are nine other
companies in the world at Manu
manufactur Pest and and as a matter of
fact the largest one is in China and we
get a lot of our clothes that are
manufactured over there so they're
coming in with PFS Coatings there's I
don't know how we would have even stop
that but maybe California is going to
try that being said for due
out ah I can't find it 90% of the past
that's in our
waste uh solid waste uh facilities comes
from food packaging alone
90% there are studies that have been
done by both
uh I want to say uh what is it uh oh
several universities and I I just I have
papers on it but I'm sorry I'm my brain
isn't as fast as it once was there are a
number of studies that show that pest
leeches out of the food packaging and
goes into the food almost instantly of
that packaging being put on the food
there have been blood tests that show
how the pest has increased in people's
blood from the minute they step in to
the minute after they finish a meal that
comes from McDonald's or comes from even
uh microwave
popcorn so the past that's going into
the waste is leeching out and is going
into our
groundwater and as a result of that our
groundwater's being polluted and
remember remember I said 90% of the
pollution that's in the pest pollution
in the waste is coming from pest at of
food
packaging so that's the setting that
we're in and the only way we're going to
stop this is by not allowing it into the
state and there's there's bills in 24
States and there's current active bills
that have actually been enacted in 12
states to stop this and unfortunately we
happen to be in an area that's been hard
hit worse than most
others we have the highest pediatric
cancer rate in the country we have the
second highest breast cancer rate in the
country we have the highest bladder
cancer rate in the country we are being
polluted all over the place and it's not
just pest but that's a part of
it and I think as a legislative body one
of the things we have to do is try and
protect ourselves as best we can and
this is something something that's easy
to do so when we last met John
suggested uh representative hunt
suggested that we combine the two
bills since then Karen eel eel has
worked to combine the two
bills and set up and more definition
with the Clearing House and worked with
num MOA and Dees num MOA is the
Northeast Waste Management official
Association and they are uh collections
of Dees officials in the Northeast that
work on these kinds of things and they
put together model legislation which I
just got the other day it's a little
more broad than what we want it still is
it's better than it was but it's still a
broad but Karen has been able to uh work
with that and work with the bill that
came out of Vermont and has set up
something and the way we're doing it the
way we're doing it is this
rather than tighten up the definition of
past because some people want it to be
defined this way some people want it to
find that way all different ways we're
just saying in these four products and
the four products are food packaging
carpeting children's toys and dental
floss in these four products no
pasas you can put it anywhere else you
want but yet not putting it in there
we're going to protect the
kids we're going to protect our food
source
and keep it out of your mouth for
goodness
sake because the really the some of the
new uh the new uh Dental flosses are
very very slippery because they have
pasas in
them and you don't need that in your
mouth and because it's rubbing against
your
out so we don't want to really tighten
up the uh loose tighten up the
definition now what the EPA has done and
I have the law right here so if anybody
wants to question it 155
Pages what the EPA has done is they said
we're going to create a registry now
they're not g they won't
include breakdown products which I think
is a mistake but they said they can't at
this time that doesn't mean they won't
1447 PS chemical
definitions and they what they're doing
is they're tracking every everybody who
makes any of this stuff or makes a
product that contains this stuff has to
put it in their registry once it's in
the registry they will decide in a few
years from now which are the ones that
are coming in and that are hurting us
the most and then they will make the
laws then laws will be enacted if
Congress wants to otherwise EPA doesn't
have that
ability what we want to do is we're
going to say just these four products
that's the end of it you put them on the
registry if you make any of these
products you put it on the registry you
swear that you're not going to put any
past in them and you put and you present
specific data now we have several of
these Clearing Houses already in
existence in the Northeast there's about
four of them in fact one of them was set
up by our own Dees for mercury so it' be
the same kind of thing just the same
exact kind of thing like the Mercury one
and the reason why I'm not in a hurry to
pass these bills right now is that
database hasn't been set up
yet so it'll be set up very shortly but
they need these they need a bill to push
it to get the to get the things set up
so what I ask of you is this if we put
these two bills and I'm looking at you
representative
hunt if we put these two bills on
interim study for now so that we can
have representative eel's bill which
does the things we talked about can we
commit to the fact that first of all
that bill will come
here and you can do your little magic I
can and if it when it does come here we
give it a fair
things you haven't shed enough blood
today um so no the I mean obviously the
speaker makes that choice and I I will I
will speak to the speaker and then we'll
bring it and ab a fair hearing and and I
would say it it'll absolutely get a fair
hearing you know the obviously the big
touchy point is the the one one polymer
or two or more polymer and and and the
food packaging because the the
Department of Health and Human Services
is very leery how they're because they
they see themselves as the regulator of
that rather than uh Waste Systems so
those having I'm just telling you now
what I know will be the issues okay but
and so but absolutely we'll have a fe
hearing and absolutely will you know
work work to find a resolution you know
it's mean I have to say when once I
found out about the Mercury uh and and
this the Clearing House concept um I
knew that that was was a winner and that
that was the right way to go and that
because it's we're not creating a new a
new system a new process that that that
that's what we're doing now so in my
mind that is if you're ever gonna
address the PFS problem that is the way
it generally
not I think I'm signed on to so many
bills this year it's just it's you know
too much too
much so thanks oh you okay so yes we
collab just really quickly um as the
owner of food service operation
basically um these Clearing Houses
already exist here in the state so when
I am ordering I generally select things
that are pasos free it just needed you
to know that it already is in existence
these companies that are basically
National and international they already
have these things in place because other
states are protecting against it and
they're trying to be preemptive I would
guess of the liability issues and they
care about the welfare of the people
they're feeding so um I have that um
concern with the products that I am
purchasing and I just need you to know
that this is already in
existence okay okay but it's not
mandatory it is not right right and and
I one thing I've have been amazed at and
my wife ly said here we've been every
time I have an opportunity to ask people
about do you have past or know anything
about past they all look at me like I
have three heads on I mean evidently p
is the best is not out there and I mean
even in a furniture store they have no
idea about people there A lot of
uneducated people well I don't know if
it's educated I would not say that I'm
an un educated person the only reason I
know about p is because you know I read
the newspaper about what happened in
marac you know if it hadn't if it hadn't
happened at peas you know for the fire
retardant materials and and marac with
one Factory I don't think I would known
pasas so any rate so the motion that
representative spear will take each one
up at the separately um we'll start out
with with uh this the first one on the
list
465 representative spear um moves to
interim
study 465 and and 242 well we'll do
we'll do them each separately
okay
yeah okay so just just a question about
that this is the second year yes it's
going be the second interim study where
does how does that work okay so interim
study that's good glad you asked so inim
study means uh this bill will hit the
house floor the first week of January so
um don't want to miss that
week because every committee has the
same same issue that that first week and
then this I think the in the second week
all the bills are going to be all these
bills are going to hit the floor
everything that was uh retained and um
and it once it's if the interim study is
passed by the full body uh that means we
will will get a chance to talk about
this again next
September and that would be after we've
taken action on whatever bill so it uh
historically we always you know we say
in at that time and then at that time
the vote is recommended or not
recommended for future legislation but
that would obviously be depending about
whatever happens to Evil's bill this
coming year but yes we will get to talk
Fall this bill can come up in the next
session correct whether it's inter study
or not or not recommended for uh
legislation correct well the key element
is that if um if we if we kill a bill
you can't reintroduce it okay interim
study is not not a kill motion even
though people call it Killing Me Gently
but it's not a kill motion it it's the
bill is still alive so absolutely the
bill in in the the subject matter can be
reinduced in the second year but not the
second year but next session well the
next session it's it's a clean slate
exactly you know every every you get you
could you could bring in the same issue
every two years for the rest of your
life if you as long as you keep getting
elected right so I don't know why why
interim study how is it how is that
rather than kill it no well interim
study is to show that we still care
about this issue we have a vehicle to
talk about it and and has it's just a
baseline so no I I have no problem with
inter and then and then the issue comes
down to is next year whether it's
recommended for future legislation or
not recommended and at that point in
time we'll talk about we'll talk about
what happened slowly and it informs it
keeps keeps it keeps the issue alive so
I mean other issues it's like the
committee committee could always talk
about a certain subject matter and and
have that subject matter around so yes M
Spirit we talked about just a little bit
about the definition of what PS is right
and the way it is in the these the two
bills that we have here that we've been
talking about is that it can be as small
as one carbon
Florine pair if you will and there's
been objections to that in the case of
pmoa their definition is one fully
fluorinated carbon and one partially
fluorinated carbon pair one and a half
yes killing me it's not really one and a
is part of the problem is is
hfos hfos are a a a type of uh
past that the EPA does not consider past
dangerous because hfos that's the
chemical that's used in like uh
refrigerators and stuff because as soon
as it hits the atmosphere it breaks down
pretty quick the problem with
hfos is that the breakdown
products are very toxic and they last
for 30 years and they land in the water
and they they're even even less
filterable than pz chemicals
are but I I don't I'm not trying to ban
those I you know they have a a place and
there's people who work with that and
that's some other issue that's another
issue we just want to ban whatever
chemical you're putting in food
children's toys carpets and dental
floors so it's not the definition it's
the
use yes repres representative m um I'm a
little bit confused uh I thought that
these two bills we will put on inter
term study and we look at them uh a year
from now but in the meantime this
combination bill will come up be in the
interim January and we can vote on that
is that correct yeah so yeah so we we we
actually retained this this first year
was is
retaining okay and and so um we could
have I would say is if things were
moving along fast enough faster with new
New Hampshire Mo or the New England Mota
we might have been able to amend one of
these bills with that language but the
fact is the fact the fact is that no
matter what the effective data is going
to be pushed out to 2025 anyways so it's
just that that that the uh and I'm
honoring represent spe and represent EV
the sponsor that you know they they
requested that we would just keep these
alive you know we study them uh but that
at the end day you know we'll we'll
address this issue with the next Bill
thank you okay
mot we're going to vote Yes we plan to
have another bill coming in next this
coming
January I I as you know there's many
steps in the way you know
many
so got it nobody does okay all right so
the pending motion is interim study the
business Committee just for everybody's
uh is represent Ammon Cole thaon hunt
melier Herbert Philo filio and Spear and
I see filios is missing so
uh oh that's right he's well yeah he's
that's right you can't have him you
independent
sorry you're right uh evidently this
committee is not equal not 10 10 right
with with him is okay any rate um all
those in favor of interim study please
say yay y those
opposed okay moose by oh moose
representative spear uh seconded by
and representative spear second B
representative Ammon moves um interim
motion all those in favor say I those
opposed you moved
right and last but not least House Bill
173 related to toilet facilities
provided by restaurants do we we have an
amendment
yet we do it's in my email I came from I
forwarded it to you it still appears to
be stuck in my email it came came from
uh was supposed to go to the service
what do they call it
here HCS HCS it went to HCS who I guess
was supposed I thought was supposed to
distribute it to everybody but we don't
have it so so okay all right um other
than that it's done it's pretty simple
you have it right now on your computer
right I do okay uh can I yeah I want her
you to send it to Carri one on our
phones yes if you all got it on your
have well I couldn't tell it it got it
said it was stuck so I hit it a couple
times yeah I got it from so it's from
you right yes all right just repeal okay
it's pretty simple if you're it's pretty
simple you just read it that's what I
was thinking it's it doesn't seem like
it's worth the
paper uh I mean to print it out 18 times
um historically we've always uh said
that that we have to have a that that PR
C we have everybody has it in their
hands so that you you
know it's it's a security issue okay I'm
good she was there pretty simple so
do it's what the guy asked for so but I
guess I could you know every rule is
made to be broken so does everyone have
everyone have have it on their
toy oh it was just subcommittee we just
sub you want to can you just you want me
to just read it
it
bunch
right come back all right let's get
lunch all right
so
um representative taxton uh Second and
uh by
representative Hammond um moves uh a to
pass on the amendment and he's
recognized to speak to his Amendment
motion well it's not really complicated
it's not like the PF
thing uh when we when we met last time
uh the the request was made the
preference was that the uh whole section
be removed or so that's what we did and
it repeals I'll just read it for the
sake of the record uh
the motion or the amendment is to repeal
the following RSA 155 colon 40 relative
to the requirements to provide toilet
facilities in restaurants RSA 155 col 41
relative to the penalty for failure to
provide such toilet
facilities and the analysis is this bill
removes the requirement that restaurants
and other businesses that serve food to
the public provide toilet facilities for
patrons that's
it
and so we have a new member of our
committee welcome rep
MCU um and uh I think maybe we need a
little bit of catch up on the issue
around this uh bill so it's my
understanding and someone correct me if
I'm wrong that there are building codes
that supersede this and corre and make
this statute obsolete right that was the
real point the the building it's not
like restaurants are no longer going to
have bathrooms right uh the point of
this was this is redundant and there
were so many exceptions in it as it was
with but you have to have a you don't
have to have a bathroom if you're if
you're a food truck if you're a hot dog
stand and various other things so the
suggestion was made since it's already
covered in building code that this the
whole section be
eliminated makes sense yeah I watched a
lot of YouTube hearings uh but I thought
this one was simple enough I could Skip
and evidently not so thanks for the
catchup y
yes okay everybody else said right
everybody remembers remembers that day
right so this is still the business this
is business
still okay uh so oh all those in favor
of ought to pass on the amendment please
raise your hand sorry one two three four
five six seven okay seven zip uh
representative
ta representative taxon second by
representative Ammon moves uh ought to
pass as amended any discussion on the
motion seeing none the clerk does not
need to call the
role all those in favor say I right all
oppos so moved
done um I just want to um let everybody
know the first bill we're going to be
taking up the liquor
bill and um there there was a you guys
got it mailed out to you late last night
and I did not have a chance to read it
uh and I am making a couple of changes
on it um and and
um and if you have it near you uh what
where is that on the section one uh
cannot exceed we the current law is 10
days so we want to keep the current law
10 days but that's only if all the
employees have had
training and then the UN Roman numeral
well un R little little
eye um the second offense uh uh up has
30-day would still be the up to that
still leaves the commission to decide
whether that uh was really um the
situational situation which is the way
we've over always handled it with the
Liquor Commission so that is what I
would like to take up as an
amendment but otherwise uh we'll see you
all at uh well those who are on the
liquor committee at
1:5 and then health is uh what do I have
one 140 is it yeah it must have been
145 yeah
yeah 145
okay if you're if you're on the business
committee you're all done for the
day unless you want to see all the
afternoon
for
I
what's that 198
what's oh yeah okay yeah the social yeah
and
um
uh okay obviously this is a work in
progress um and we have been moving
along in terms of coming up with the
right
language um so at this point this is
where I'm at and I if we can discuss and
if anybody want to take take differ
opinions to
subcommittee judges Ru
in okay all right um to start out with
is um I know the the original bill was
introduced as
Elizabeth law um the problem when you
put a name on a on on a bill is that
name
disappears you know it's not in the
statute and um I have had times where
people said well I thought you guys
passed this law and I go you know you
know so I as much as I I want everyone
to know that we are taking up this
legislation now uh in her honor and
that's important that we are but at the
same time um putting her name in the
rsas uh is not it's not and I have no
control over it's just not going to
happen it's not it would be lost um and
and I hate to you know have a in and
someone say why why didn't you tell us
that that was going to happen so I'm I'm
just going to be upfront that um I think
if um if they look up the B the bill
then I think they'll probably reference
uh Elizabeth cro if you I mean if you
Google it or you know whatever if you
you know that will pop up no no no it's
gone it just once it's when it's in the
RSA right not so the only time that name
is there is is chapter law okay and the
chapter is those yellow books I don't
knowbody you ever SE they every year
they try to get us to take the yellow
books and right I've seen them and they
have extra ones and nobody Wars them and
that's the only place it'll ever be yeah
so and I I just I just want to be
straight because I think this is
important legislation and and um and I
think it's important that that you know
we get it done and we don't you know
without any pretense of what else it
could be or not be
um having said that uh I have to
emphasize to everyone that this
committee has had this legislation about
changing um the 10
days multiple times it's not this is not
the first time we're revisiting it it
just happens to be coincidentally that
we're now doing it when the department
is working on their rules anyways so it
it worked out this is a good time for us
to revisit
this
um I think and I and I proposed it
before that the most important thing
that this committee is going to get
across is how important training is that
we need these employees to be trained
and we need employers to not think
that's a place where they can save money
and cut costs
so if nothing else with this bill is
what we're trying to do here is impress
upon um lenes the importance of of that
so having said that um uh I I think
we'll we're will leave the 10 days but
they have have to get the training which
is uh representative kill's bill that
he's put in multiple times over the
years and we've never passed but that we
are now going to pass it and um that
that that 30 days uh but then if in
given the severity of the case um that
it's not going to stop at 10: it it can
go all the way up to 30 uh and that and
that is done through the hearing process
by the by The Liquor
Commission um and then going on to the
second offense um and that seven off is
is within a seven-year
window um and at that point um you know
that that uh
the training the training issues
didn't the window of training is gone uh
so now we we were going to go at least a
minimum of 15 days up to 30
days um and as much as uh you know the
hospitality business or you know
restaurants would say 30 days is a is
this you might as well be
revocation um they're going to have to
make that case to the commission that
that whatever happened was not you know
it's not worth worthy of the 30 days
so um and then of course the third
events is
revocation but hopefully that will never
ever
happen so that's that's where I'm at and
I'm certainly willing to to listen to
anybody have any feelings or
differences on that but it seems to
balance both sides but gets what I think
is the most important thing is to
emphasize how important is training the
training
is
MH
okay um so if everybody's okay then
that's what the amendment that will look
like when we take it up on November
7th so I will also I will because we
don't have the official Amendment um I
will schedule a
subcomittee um
at
7th
12 okay no that was that was don't you
remember who made that was it was George
senior Bush made that
mistake he was he came in in September
7th and he said this day will live in in
um looks good yeah if you want you know
certainly yeah
yeah thank you members of the committee
for the record I'm Moren money a state
representative from the town of marac
I'm here with Mr and Mrs croak today day
uh you may recall their very compelling
testimony from earlier this year and
their advocacy and idea for this bill I
we're very appreciative of the work that
you and the committee has put into this
and we look forward to taking it through
the process uh in June when hopefully
the governor will sign it uh as it is I
also want to make mention that I want to
thank in particular the governor who has
written now two letters of support for
House Bill 279 two the second one
arrived today and I have a copy if you
don't have one already also want to
thank the Liquor Commission for their
help and guidance and support of this
you thank
you all right we all set with
that
okay I guess we could do a straw poll
right draw a vote okay so uh St all
those who will be in favor of this
amendment please raise your hand
one two three four five six okay all
right
it no because we're all here the liquor
oh for the next for the next uh few oh
Insurance yeah I'm not voting either but
I'll help
paperwork
no you're good to go if you want to go
yeah I mean a lot of you know a lot of
people just stay anyway because they
want to hear how it went but I
mean
if I think you could speak
if you want you're not on the sub
right
for
okay
uh last but not least Health uh health
insurance bills okay first up Senate
Bill 198 directing the insurance
department to conduct a cost study of
providing coverage or certain reprodu
productive health
Alex
good D your microphone and then I I told
because my wife was here earlier that
you people have to really pull this
thing close to your mouth so if you
you're talking to it and if you can't
hear
yourself that means nobody else can hear
you so you you actually you know they
they have it real well Ed so you can we
don't have feedback but you do need to
hold it very close to your to
mouth
okay
perfect so um introduce
yourself I'm Alex Fel uh Health reform
instructor for the insurance
department I'm Michelle heat and I'm the
health law policy legal
council welcome and uh the two of us um
were interacted with the external
Actuarial firm that did the cost study
um on this
bill um
and it's posted on our
website um and would
you like to hear a short description of
the findings uh we we like the executive
summary well I'll give you even shorter
than that um the um study um divides the
costs of up uh into two categories
um um one sort of General category for
assisted reproductive
treatment and uh separate category for
preservation um and uh in order to make
uh uh this calculation about cost First
there was a calculation about the number
of people who would be eligible for the
services
um and then an estimation of the number
of people who would use the services and
then that was multiplied by uh an
estimation of the cost per Service uh
for a variety of services that
um are
involved um and the uh first part of the
study um found used a low medium and
high
estimate um because it's very hard
to uh pick numbers about the number of
people who will be using the service um
so it's more common to use this range um
and the cost was expressed as a per
member per month amount so you can think
of that as monthly
premium um um and the low estimate U for
the first part of the coverage was
2525 and the high estimate was $1100
$50.2 um so those are large numbers um
when you're looking at mandate coverage
um estimates generally um
um and then for the preservation part of
I'm looking for
that oh there we
go um um two questions before we go on
um again this is only affecting the
small group right we're only the large
group and and the large
group only the large group only the
large group so excluding individual
market and small group Market in order
to uh avoid that um issue the oh right
the unfunded mandate under the UN
Affordable Care Act yeah so we could we
can force this onto large employer or
large employers being the
of over 51 to 100 is that 51 and above
51 up yeah who were still buying the
fully insured product rather than the
being an aressa right so how many how
many lives were they they thinking that
that that was going to pick
up well um the total um oh there it is I
was just going to plug head 237,000
okay 237 237,000 is the potential pool
but it's very difficult to estimate how
many people would actually utilize these
serves so that's why we have the low
medium and high So based on the low
medium high estimates I think the low
uptake was around 6,000 and high uptake
23,700 right so if we think that the
average premium of the large employer is
going to
be 600 500
10% yes this would be a sub holy moly
so part of the problem with this mandate
study is that the language in the
proposed bill was very broad so that
opened up um a large variety of
potential services that would be
included and there's also language in
the bill that this would be for a c
certain classes of people however that
would be discriminatory to just single
out certain classes to allow to give
them the covered benefit so we took we
kind of disregarded that because would
be discriminatory and we applied it to
anyone that would be eligible for these
services so those two factors really
increase the cost um if there's um going
to be efforts to try to bring down the
cost some of the suggestions would be to
limit the types of services or put in
some kind of parameters about what
specific Services would be covered and
in one what instances and that could
potentially bring down the cost but um
okay this this study considered that why
wide variety of services so that's why
the um amount is full spectrum
yes yeah it was a little bit unusual
usually we get the um proposed mandate
already expressed in legislative
language and then it gets referred to us
and this was this bill was actually
itself about
referring um mandate and we struggled
very much with questions of
interpretation
great okay why don't you keep going did
unless did we get everything yeah the
second part uh you know of the coverage
that was um
evaluated I've lost the pages but it was
also uh significant numbers um you're on
it uh the low end was $9 PM pm and the
highend was $35 PM pm um and the middle
was
18 um for the preservation part of the
services yeah you're you're got to speak
a little
louder okay I'll start over
yeah the uh the low uh for as a Express
and per member per month for the
preservation Services was $9 the high
was
$35.50 in the middle was
$18 per member per month yeah so well
some preservation of egg and spr egg
that's right
Chiller
okay all right sen represent Terry so as
I understand it in your initial
presentation here or report to us you're
saying that you're finding the language
of the bill as being overly Broad
and also a second problem is that it's
it on its face is
discriminatory uh well no The Way It Was
Written had it seemed to leave no stone
unturn in terms of all the circumstances
so there wasn't any kind of parameters
that would have limited to how who we
could get the benefit so so therefore
would would you might not conclude that
the the the Bill's language needs work
and and would be open to amendment to to
yeah to to uh address the concerns that
you have articulated yes um we've
because you didn't say that but I'm I'm
kind of inferring that from oh
absolutely your very there's uh the
potential here for um designing
legislation that um Works in response to
the report to um limit the coverages uh
to more closely align with I think what
was
intended so yes if I may follow so so
you what I'm hearing is that the bill
that you're that you studied the
language that you studied you would
consider to
be less than
desirable and and and defective I don't
mean to be pajora of here but it's it's
deficient and defective and needs to be
rectified in order to be able to be
viable
so what was actually in the bill that
was presented to us was really a bill to
create a cost study report and it gave
um some very general parameters it's not
necessarily written in the context of if
you were to um Implement a new mandate
it was not written in that context it
was really just to do this cost study
but when we did the cost study there was
no specifics really put into it so
that's why we ended up having to do do
this very general very broad considering
a whole spectrum of services so it we
would recommend if you want to bring
down the cost in future legislation
because this was just to do the study
and the study's done so I'm not sure
that you would necessarily want to move
forward with this but if you want to um
introduce some new legislation on this
issue um it would be advisable to
include some definitions or some
parameters about what specifically um
you representative
pelli do you know if uh did you look at
other states to see what their
experiences were how many other states
so we did not do the analysis Freeman
did the analysis and they did review
other states no state has um legislation
that's this broad that would remove um
the requirement of medical necessity we
do in New Hampshire already have a
mandate on par U ility Services in the
large group Market but that is limited
to what's medically necessary and I
believe this um the intention behind
this type of legislation was to expand
that
coverage thank you very
much all right
uh obviously I I guess first I want to
make sure everybody understands that
little conversation that Alex and I had
just had there and that is when the
Affordable Care Act was passed uh back
when they called it Obamacare I guess
and uh when it was passed um they they
were going to originally the concept was
they were going to come up with a menu
of mandates that were going to be uh
consistent and through throughout the
country and and then they've realized
that that was extremely problematic
because every state had different
mandates had different elements so they
um you could call it the Kick the Can
down the road what they said instead was
that um okay each state is stuck with
the mandates that they
have and that after going forward if you
want to pass a new health insurance
mandate uh and this may be reason why we
haven't seen too many since then uh is
that the state would have to pay for the
Mandate so the Sation that I I guess I
had you know I I knew that the uh small
employer you know was was uh 2 to
50 in New Hampshire we actually we were
one that was we were kind of
controversial with our 1 to 50 but but
we that it was 2 to 50 and then and then
um when our what we call our fully
insured Market um was large employers
are 51 and and up so saying that uh so I
guess this is a a Learning lesson for
everyone if you see a health insurance
mandate be aware that you're not
affecting the small employer or the
individuals which is really ones who
would be hurt the most by any new
mandate in terms of Premium increase but
that um is only into employers that are
51 or greater that have not switched to
an Arisa plan that they are just still
in the fully insured Market which we
just learned there are two 130 some
businesses who were in that which yeah
excuse me so and that's that's a good
you know that's good
20 whatever States population million
six so that's a you know a pretty high
number
so okay uh who would like to uh make an
an expedient legislation motion okay
representative Terry anybody want to
Second it represent
collabro
any discussion on the motion of
inexpedient to legislate seeing none all
those on the health committee say I I
those
supposed six Z 6
Z
okay all
right next up uh Senate bill 35 relative
service provide through a primary care
behavioral health
model
okay and you guys have been spending a
lot of time working on this I
hope right
so and others is is Alex when is his
convers off by budget or how do how do
we how do we handle consultants in our
in our budget it's part of the secret
sauce Mr chairman I consider Alex to be
a uh successfully failed retiree failed
at trying to retire
right so yeah there was um a good amount
of work um done on this bill um we felt
we had a mandate from this committee um
to see what we could do by bringing the
stakeholders together both the carriers
and uh mental health providers who um
were trying to uh bill under this
Primary Care behavioral health model of
care wow you really you're kind of
mellowed in your old age that was always
you were so much louder when you were
when you were the deputy
dog
okay um there was good representation in
the working group both from uh Mental
Health Providers and from the carriers
and um a spirit of uh collaboration so
it was kind of fun to work with this
group um the problem um that seems to
have been occurring which we verified in
looking at the claims data there was a
fairly High denial rate for the specific
codes um that were being build for this
service um is that uh some of the codes
are quite new this model of care is new
um and uh it's not easy to build
correctly or to um process the bills
correctly uh because it's a new thing um
so we identified that as one of the
issues and then uh there was um
a subset or one issue in particular uh
that seemed to be causing the most
problem uh which was that um a lot of
these bills that were developed uh by
those entities that um develop these
codes um set up uh this mechanism where
the the
payment uh has to be or the bill has to
be submitted by the billing provider
which which um in this model would be
the um primary care
provider um and uh that makes it
difficult for someone who uh for example
just has a contractual relationship with
the primary care provider which is one
way of setting up this model uh to then
have to build only through that provider
is um difficult um so we identified some
codes that we believe believe can be
used for billing
directly and um we are we have a
bulletin that the department will issue
um basically providing instruction to
the carriers to make a special effort to
review the claims that are coming in
associated with this care model um to
identify issues and most importantly to
reach out to the providers and uh um
make sure that they are making clear
what the uh procedure is for building
under these new
codes so that's the
plan thank you Mr chairman what I would
add to that and the reason why I wanted
to come up here is to share with you
what that bulletin process is I don't
think we've had an opportunity to talk
about that in any of the times that the
department has appeared before the
committee so as all of you well know try
as hard as you might when you craft a
piece of legislation when you put a new
statute into effect it's impossible in
all circumstances to get it exactly
right which is why you all have the Jael
car process which helps to smooth out
the rough edges to help with the
implementation process uh to build up
the structure around that law to ensure
that you are achieving what was intended
in the
statute for Regulators for us we have
another tool that can help with that
process and it's called the bullet
process and so while it does not have
the effect of Law and while we do not
have to come before the legislature to
achieve it what it essentially amounts
to is based off of the statute or the
rule if there is a rule in place for
this this is how the department is going
to interpret the most appropriate way
for us to regulate this particular
statute or Rule and so what Alex was
able to do was to bring the stakeholders
together in a very collaborative of way
and say we can actually achieve this by
the department clarifying how it wants
this process to go forward and so the
beauty of that is we can issue that
bulletin at any moment and it will go
into effect at that moment and hopefully
we can start to iron out some of the
issues here I will tell you that this is
not the only circumstance where we have
seen this type of thing uh the state has
brought on a number of different
Services uh over the past several years
um that need to have that billing
process ironed out and so I think what
we've done here is created a very
successful model for us to go forward
and address some of these other issues
Arenas I I I would have to say that I
too have urged you guys to do a
bulletins over the years and and usually
would it's it's a it's a procedural
thing and it's just letting the
companies know exactly how they should
handle it
and so so yes representa Terry so would
it be correct for me to understand that
in your conversations with the parties
involved in this issue that all are are
satisfied if not in agreement that this
is the way to
proceed yeah I I think there's um a good
consensus that um this is a good way to
proceed uh we're doing taking the
unusual step um
in this case of circulating a draft
bulletin with that group to make sure
that um we have that um consensus good
thank you yeah and having said that
because I'm looking at John who is the
my uh best way to handle a situation
like this is that uh we will um interim
study the bill and so that a year from
now you can come back and uh when we
when we take up interim studies you can
come back and tell us or John can tell
us what what has been the outcome of
this bulletin and whether it's it's been
as successful as we would hope
so
okay thank you very much John you want
in
me of
committee thank you Mr chair members of
the committee for the record my name is
John dejoy I'm representing the New
Hampshire Psychological Association and
and what the commissioner and Alex have
just uh outlined is we agree with
completely uh we we my client is
requesting that we not go to interim
study just yet we would like to see the
draft bolon because they if depending on
the draft bullet if we're able to iron
everything out which we think we have
have um we're happy to either inm study
or kill the bill at that point however
if not then they want to keep open the
option for a couple more weeks to move
the bill forward it is our expectation
that the bullton will resolve things
once we can see the draft that is the
expectation we're working
under okay so how long will you guys
Bulletin
days okay because so we're we're
scheduling to exact this bill on the 7th
November
7th
so bulletin should be on the
street as I said please don't hear this
as expecting an adverse outcome we
expect a positive outcome it's just my
client would like to see The Bu front
you like to see the eyes dotted and the
t's crossed okay okay so we'll we'll
hold up for our final uh decision on
that
come come November
7th okay all right that's fine we can
hold off no
problem
um I mean I guess we
could because we're gonna come back
we're going to come back and I mean I
but I wouldn't schedule another com so
so let's just do let's do the interim
study motion but that if the bulletin
comes out and and if it's okay um you
know so let's take up the inter room
study so so I move um interim study
cabro before we vote question yes
so by taking this tact of interim
studying it yeah it it's easier to
withdraw it on the 7th rather than to
well does to make a motion to interim
study it on the 7th
right we generally generally six to one
half doesn't the other I mean you're
preferring that we enter and study it
and then withdraw it if everything works
out exactly thank you
yeah okay is the motion clear all those
in favor say I those opposed so move
unanimously
okay all
right let me just
make
uh
okay um relative to insurance coverage
for Pain Management Services
303 represent
collabro I would like to bring new life
into this bill I have talked to um its
sponsors
today um what I've taken the time to do
most of the summer is basically working
on HB 66 which is a study to study the
integrative uh model of collaborative
medicine for chronic pain in the state
non-
pharmaceutically what you have is five
members of the House and Senate
basically sitting there um every two
weeks doing research about this and some
of us have gone offsite and done some
research to find out how can we in
bottom line is make this efficient
effective reduce emergency room visits
reduce the stress on providers like
myself and keep them from retiring
really young and and allow us to have
some solutions here and it becomes very
obvious over time that the economic
model of expanding care to include those
licenses um medical licenses in the
state for those supportive systems
they're less invasive they have better
efficacy they cost less and in UVM it
showed us very
plainly that six months of operation
within their chronic Integrative
Medicine model and there are only 10 per
um 10 participants in that of that six
month study that was the same cost as
one and a half epidural injections as a
PCP I find out that people have chronic
pain because of how many times they've
gone to urgent care emergency rooms how
many time has been wasted how they're
abusing the
vicadin I see this from the other side
and so I'm trying to open this channel
of treatment options for everybody
without a mandate because I think in
time they're going to see what I already
know with my degree in community health
and psychology and in medicine that this
is a better model it's more effective
it's going to free up a lot of things
it's going to save marriages and I could
tell you that the coorbit disorders
associated with chronic pain obesity
diabetes congestive heart failure we are
tackling all of that now me as the
mobile crisis medical lead of the state
I'm trying to save
lives I want to save people from bik and
when they lose their jobs and lose their
insurance and can no longer see their
pcps that they don't turn to the street
for
fentel and that's what I'm hoping to
accomplish with this now I spoke to the
members of this committee who are not in
the same party as me and they are all in
agreement with what we are trying to do
here and I would like to see the
insurance companies do the right thing
in time I know a lot of them have
already seen that
and they see that the benefits can be
helpful but I want to limit what we
permit there has to be guard rails and
that includes lure for the state if they
deemed us capable of practicing medicine
we should be reimbursed for it now I
won't get into how much that fee for
service is because if you knew
acupuncture only yielded $18 per
injection you would know that that's not
a very affordable sustainable model but
that's what I'm trying to tackle with HB
66 not with
you would you like to make a
motion I would love for us to take it
seventh sorry I would move to interim
study no we are not talking about an
interim study we want to move forward on
it I told you I got the entire group to
agree do we move forward with it non-man
ated but as
Amendments okay I guess if you that's
what you were trying to tell me earlier
I'm sorry I totally missed that um the
the sponsor asked me to in and he
corrected his CH changed it which is
what I told you before we came in here
he does not want to put it into interim
study he wants us to move forward he
agreed yeah well okay well we're a long
way I mean when I when I plugged in the
bill and pulled up the bill and said
change all the all the no shs to he sent
it he sent it to us a few weeks ago the
amended bill yeah but I I took what he
sent me and I turned all the shs to May
there was 25 of
them that's what I I but we didn't get
that amend we have we don't have that
Amendment what do you mean we don't have
the amendment that says
May you need the amend I thought he'd
send that into OSS okay I'll get him to
do that but that's that is what we had
talked
about well he obviously I you saying he
tried to call me or talking no he sent
the corrected amended and you corrected
it but I never got those revisions from
you
no I I don't think
so who's on
[Music]
first yeah I I
don't I mean at this at this point he he
told me to interum study the bill and he
changed that when I told him that we had
support here from other people and that
we would not mandate conversation with
him that we and I had that conversation
when we walked in here and I tried to
explain to you that he would like to
pull this spell out of retention Gary
Merchant would like to pull this spell
out of retention Dave lungren would like
to pull this spell out of retention and
I would like to pull the spell out of
attention we're trying to expand healthc
care access without a mandate I don't
see that being complicated
thing
Well here here's the problem what the
bill
does even if even if we turn everything
into May okay is a whole new process
procedure and what he told me was that
he he they wanted to pursue that in ' 66
we are we're just let's work on the
wording and the amendment let's take
what whatever it is that you're
contending without out but that is
essentially what he wants to see happen
is that we limit it to 12 visits that we
include those professions that have the
license
sure and that we not make it a mandate
the How We Do It Is HP 66's Legacy well
but the whole idea is this whole new way
of looking at Health that's HB 66's
Legacy not this part that was what we
talked
about uh Mr chairman so uh so how do how
how how does how do the two relate then
why is one necessary for the other I
mean just just for illumination so that
some of us on this side who are right
now trying to understand what's going on
here I mean it's it's it's so confusing
I'll just be right now gener if I
were to for me to address chronic pain
for a patient I have three or four
people I can call in my tools in my tool
belt okay what we're trying to do is
expand with those codes whatever those
things for that chronic pain that we
extend it to various other entities who
are licensed through the state as well
acupuncture Chiropractic most insurance
companies are starting to include that
but not all of
them they're more effective Solutions
sometimes shorter quicker res resolution
and avoidance of er might follow up so
so I'm still trying to understand the
relationship between the two bills and
how they relate to each other HB 66 was
mandated
by what I've been asked to do by the
speaker is essentially find a model for
the state to deal with collaborative
medicine um to deal with chronic pain we
are trying to do that it's a bipartisan
effort these stakeholders here today are
there for that particular committee as
well and the research that we're doing
is basically trying to figure out how to
solve that problem for the state I
highly doubt we'll get it done by
December we will probably extend it
through the following year and work on
that as creating a collaborative model
what this is trying to extend is
coverage for those services for chronic
pain to include the other
providers okay but not mandate the costs
and not mandate that they have to cover
it in time they'll see that it is useful
and it is going to save them money and
that it is a more efficient model
research has shown that since um 2010 so
I don't know how long you want to
prolong this we're in brief recess for
five minutes while I call call
Dave Nel I have this
number so are these so like the
acupuncturists and whatever are they not
now covered they're not considered
providers so this bill wants to consider
wants to make it but not mandate that
they be provid because now we're going
from Shell to May that's right so so so
isn't this still then very if May
becomes permissive so what are we
accomplish
by making this permissive because it's
opening the
door what we already know so so are you
saying they need nudges these the
insurance
people I don't want any
insurance I want to come to
in
so why don't we have one bill instead of
two it makes it more complicated to have
one bill instead of two no to make two
bills well no well no actually you're no
actually you're describing what's going
complicated so we want to have a
collaborative model but we don't want to
mandate it on the insurance companies we
want them to do it but we need to use
language like May which is an effect of
which is therefore has the effect of a
resolution right a resolution which says
this is the sense of the legisl the
legislature has the sense that this is
where we would like you to go we're not
mandating you to do this at this point
yes yes
well from a favorable point of view
would say this is quite elegant this
procedure on the other hand I would say
it's some
convoluted
side okay so what what I would like to
that
so
ex we have does this get easier on the
last
bill I just know nothing ever gets EAS
here
okay all right let me make sure I got
this
down we'll be able to legally gummies
leg
least relative prompt payments for
manage
aware what's the force of
that's you know just like nice be
nice oh my God are you gonna read that
are these the
handouts Jesus do we do we get one of
them do we get
this these are something visuals these
are visuals
[Laughter]
PowerPoint there was PowerPoint yeah we
we got to help our uh tree tree Paper
Industries here look all the paper we we
just have PowerPoint that's right he was
asking me for he was asking for a
PowerPoint and I said no there's no
PowerPoint we got no stinking power
points is this recycled paper or is this
a virgin no I it's you know Jean
help that sounds like Jean yeah that
sounds like Jean that's why I beat them
there there's just too many trees I know
out yeah you know we throw everything
glass you drive into the transfer
station and all this is recycling
mandatory it's got all that glass paper
whatever and then it says all right only
glass thank you Mr chairman members of
the committee once again my name is DJ
beton Court I have the pleasure serving
as the commissioner of the New Hampshire
insurance department Department you have
met Michelle previously you have met
Alex previously but wisely hiding
somewhere in the back there is Jason
Dexter the head of our life and health
Division and collectively they have put
this afternoon's presentation together
for you as we promis that we would while
today's discussion is
obenson a bill 82 which is prompt
payment of
claims we appreciate and we hope as a
result of this presentation that you
will appreciate that there there are
deeper underlying currents at play that
have prompted this legislation beyond
the narrow definition of prompt pay and
so therefore we have crafted a
presentation that hopefully provides you
with some of the critical information
about the core issues that many of you
indicated to us that you have been
hearing
about as you will hear under the narrow
definition of prompt pay there are no
issues in New Hampshire our carriers are
paying claims slightly faster than the
national average that being said at the
same time we know that there are issues
with varying degrees of prominence which
account with accounts receivable that
carriers owe to
Providers therefore I believe we can
logically deduce that the issue is not
prompt pay as this legislation
contemplates but something more complex
and deep we are going to share with you
what we believe those issues are based
on our observations and Analysis however
fundamentally there are two major issues
the first is that the billing system is
mind-numbingly
complicated and the second issue is that
human
beings all of which of us are of course
fallible are trying to navigate that
incredibly complex
system this is not to say that those who
are responsible for billing on both the
part of the carrier or the provider is
not working hard or they're not smart or
they're not doing their best what I am
trying to get across to you is that this
is a system that is going to have its
flaws and despite best efforts mistakes
are going to be
made therefore to help you understand
the complexity and provide context to
what carriers and hospitals are
struggling with my team is going to walk
through a presentation that seeks to
accomplish a few things walk you through
and help you understand the claims
handling and processing process they
will then detail to you the legal prompt
payment standards in current law and
then we will share with you where things
can go wrong in that system and the role
that the insurance department can play
in helping to resolve those
issues I think it's really important
that at no time and I appreciate the
fact that this has been a long-going
discussion
in the state it is not helpful to try to
view this situation through the Paradigm
of good guys and bad guys I think what
we need to focus our full attention on
is how to resolve these as I said and
we'll repeat again incredibly complex
issues what is Mission critical is
getting all to focus their entire
attention on fixing the issues and so to
help you better understand how we can do
that I will turn the presentation over
Michelle hello again my name is Michelle
heat and I'm the health law and policy
legal councel and um we don't have the
PowerPoint set up but we'll flip through
the pages together so I'll try to tell
you exactly where I am in it so um as DJ
said we want to just go over the life
cycle of a claim what goes into filing
it and the complexities of that not just
in filing it but in processing ing it
and then going through um an overview
what the New Hampshire insurance
department does so if you turn to slide
number two the
background again the purpose of this
presentation is to explain the
requirements of New Hampshire's prop pay
law and the complexities of the health
insurance CLA health insurance claim
process this information is specific to
the commercial insurance market for
major medical insurance it is not
applicable to self plans government
plans church plans Medicare Medicaid
chip
orare so that's very important to keep
in mind and this is really being um
provided as an overview for
informational purposes it's not going to
address every um hiccup that can happen
in the processing of a
claim so if you turn to the next slide
number three the life cycle of a clean
claim this is a little bit of a visual
to show you exactly what goes into uh
processing a claim first you need to
have a covered person who receives
care that um from a provider usually
that's in network that provider collects
information has to fill out a claim form
submit that claim form within a certain
amount of time and then it gets to the
health carrier and the health carrier
process that claim in accordance with
the benefits of the covered person's
plan and uh for electronic claims this
is supposed to be done within 15 days
for paper claims they have 30 days to
complete this process
we turn to the next slide number four
billing for
care so before we can even process a
claim or submit a claim there has to be
care that's provided to a covered person
um in accordance with that person's
insurance policy for covered benefits
this will typically require them to go
to an in network or preferred provider
and receive medically necessary care
sometimes that will also require prior
authorization or they may need a
referral from their primary care
provider before they can even rece
receive the care the provider also needs
to collect the covered person's most
up-to-date insurance information people
um will frequently change insurance
carriers lose coverage gain coverage and
if there's no coverage on the day of the
services then there can be no payment
for those services so it's very
important to have the most up-to-date
insurance information and then claims
need to be submitted within 90 days and
include all necessary information that
means proper billing codes relevant
modifiers proper diagnosis codes and
correct provider information including
the provider's address and NPI number so
if you turn to the next slide number
five this is a copy of a paper claim
form that's it's a standardized form so
it's the same every time you submit it
and it has a lot of basic information
the top part is um what you can't hardly
see uh because it's a little tiny is the
patient information and then the bottom
half is where you would put in um the
treatment codes diagnosis codes and mod
modify iers if they apply and all that
information and it seems like it should
be a very straightforward process but
just to give you some visuals uh these
two manuals are for hcps and CPT codes
these are full of codes that could
possibly be built so there's a Code
almost for everything and um like we
were talking about earlier we're always
coming up with new codes for new
services and this is the ICD manual this
this is specific to diagnoses and the
diagnoses have to line up properly with
the services in the CPT codes and the
hipi codes so it gets very complex and
you really need to know what you're
doing in order to fill out these forms
if um the right code is not used with
the right diagnosis code it's not going
to be covered so that's part of the pro
um I W say problem but that's part of
the process is making sure you're using
the codes properly they also need to be
used in accordance with the contract so
the provider we're talking about in
network providers here has a contract
with the carrier and there's certain
ways that they need to build things
sometimes there needs to be modifiers
sometimes that are bundled services or
unbundled so they have to be build in
accordance with the contract as well so
carrier sure we have a question here
yeah
and so the person filling out um the
claim form is she or he a uh coder a
medical uh what do they call them
it would depend on the practice but yeah
there's a lot of um medical billers who
specialize in how to use these codes
appropriately depending on the practice
size it could be you know someone that's
working in the front office of a smaller
practice yeah and if it's a hospital you
probably have um more sophisticated and
again it the number of codes depends on
the type of practice if you're um a
mental health provider for example
you're only probably dealing with a
handful of codes whereas if you're a
hospital you're dealing with a wide
variety of codes and possible
diagnoses so if the code is not uh a
proper code then that's when things go
arai and yes and we're gonna get to that
next thanks so that's all everything
that goes into just being able to submit
the code so what we're going to talk
about next is um I'm on slide six here
the prompt pay law and what exactly is
included in it claims denials claim
denials and adverse determinations the
appeals process and external review so
turning now to to um slide seven prompt
pay law which is RSA
420j 8- a and this is our prompt play
law that um sets out certain time
periods what's important to note about
prompt pay law is that it doesn't
necessarily guarantee payment what it's
really talking about is that the claim
is going to be processed within 15 days
if it's electronic or 30 days if it's um
a paper
claim and in order for it to be
processed it has to be a clean claim
claim so a clean claim definition is
there in paragraph 2 um and we're
talking about it includes all the most
current procedural codes all the
required Fields they're filled out
correctly and completely so that the
carrier can easily process the claim now
if it is a clean claim everything's
filled out but there's additional
information that's needed then the
carrier can request that additional
information the clock stops and once
they receive that additional information
the carryer now has 45 days to
adjudicate the
claim
so moving on to our next slide number
eight also included in our prompt pay
law is um an enforcement provision and
this is specific to prompt pay and it's
a little bit different than our general
enforcement Provisions but it's
important to highlight it because the
enforcement for prompt pay comes into
play when the commissioner has
determined or established a pattern of
overdue payments now the statute doesn't
Define a pattern of overdue payments but
um we follow the market
conduct regulation handbook which is
this pile here that's um put out by the
neicc and it sets standards for how to
do Market conduct examinations and
Analysis um and it's fairly uniform
across the country but each state has
its own specific laws that may um
require some tweaking but generally
according to the market regulation
handbook a 7% error rate is an
established Bank Benchmark for claim
practices that means if in the midst of
a examination we find that there's an
error rate of greater than 7% then it's
presumed that the claims are not being
handled in accordance with law if it's
less than 7% then it's presumed that
there's substantial compliance so that's
important to keep in mind we're not
expecting and it would be somewhat
unrealistic to expect that 100% of
claims are handled um correctly all the
time that would be the perfect utopian
world so moving on to um slide 9 which
is our mcast data mcast is Market
conduct annual statement that's what it
stands for and this is data that's
collected by the neic on a national
level but all state um all our state
carriers participate in it and it's a
it's a large data call of all different
kinds of information this is just a
little bit of a snapshot of some of the
information that we got out of it and we
use this as part of our market analysis
that we'll get to a little bit later but
it gives a snapshot of how New Hampshire
compares to the rest of the country so
according to this data
um out of all the claims being filed
excluding Pharmacy we have a denial rate
of
14.7% Which is less than the national
average if we're looking at um claims
for submitted by in network providers
again excluding
Pharmacy
96.25%
are for in network providers and 3.75%
are for out of network providers and
that's important because because if
you're an in network provider you
already have a contract established with
the carrier and it's a lot easier to um
have your claims processed if you're out
of network there's a lot more variables
at play so that can lead to delays in um
processing the
claims so of all the in network claims
that were
96.9% are paid within 30 days now this
does not translate to prompt pay because
our time periods are a little bit
different 30 days is more of a national
Benchmark but it does tell us that a
very large number are being paid within
that
96 uh of the ones being paid 96.9% are
being paid within 30 days so that's a
fairly quick
turnaround then of the CL in in network
claims that are
denied those are being processed um at a
rate of
91.7% within 30 days so those two
numbers give us a snapshot to show that
the claims are being adjudicated fairly
quickly and most of them are being
adjudicated for in networ claims
excluding Pharmacy within that 30
days so if you turn to the next slide
number
10 we're going to start talking about
claim denials a little so to just give
you some context in the commercial
market for calendar year 2022 there were
approximately 16.3 million claims
submitted so it's a very large number
according to our M our our chis data
there's an uh denial rate of about
10.3% and I wouldn't compare this to the
mcast data because we're kind of talking
about different things here but they're
somewhat in line so on this slide here
um on 10 there's a list according to our
chis data as some of the top reasons why
claims are denied so we have um an exact
duplicate claim information was
requested and not provided or is
incomplete and you can see see the list
and the percentage of claims that are
denied based on that reason I also want
to draw your attention to the very
bottom where we say medical necessity
this is not one of the top claims but
it's worth putting on there because
that's one of the um reasons you're
going to hear more often and according
to our's De it's only
0.65% of claims are being denied for
that medical necessity reason so when
the claim is denied for a lot of these
reasons um it's just a matter of
correcting the information on the claim
maybe submitting more information and
then the claim can be resubmitted and
processed assuming that they now have
all the correct
information um if it can't be
reprocessed because it's something like
medical necessity that's where we get
into uh the appeals and external review
process so if you turn to the next slide
on uh number 11 medical necessity EXC y
go ahead could I just interrupt you at
this point thank you this is all very um
helpful uh could you just tell us a
little bit about about more about what
the definition of medical necessity is
and who decides on what basis it is it
is going to tell us yes it is what what
a medical necessity is okay yep so we
got to Define it
great so in 420 j3 are our definitions
that are managed care and um XXV DB is
medical necessity and it means the
healthc care services or products
provided to an enrol Le for the purposes
of preventing stabilizing diagnosing or
treating an illness injury or disease or
the symptoms of an illness injury or
disease in a matter that is consistent
with generally accepted standards of
medical practice is clinically
appropriate in terms of type frequency
extent sight and duration and
demonstrate through scientific evidence
to be effective in improving Health
outcomes representative of best practice
in the medical profes and not primarily
for the convenience of the enrol or
physician or other healthare care
provider so that is the definition that
we apply throughout all of our
regulations this is the definition of
medical necessity so now so now I do
have a
question this is what I get for not
looking ahead that's
why now I always used to it used to bug
me that people would read five pages
ahead and you it couldn't stay with the
presentation okay uh so who decides what
constitutes generally accepted standards
of Medical Practice who who defines what
is generally accepted it seems like you
drive a truck through that yes so
there's generally speaking the way the
system is set up the carrier comes up
with medical guidelines for the
treatment of whatever we're talking
about that needs to be based on
scientific evidence so peer reviewed
articles research you know what's
happening in that field so that would be
put into the clinical guidelines now if
there is a dispute down the line which
is where we're going to go next as to
you know is that the most up-to-date
literature should you be considering
something else what about this study
then you can go through the appeals and
external review process and we'll get to
that
next so generally speaking a plan is
only going to re reimburse items and
services that are medically necessary
and that's pretty much the Cornerstone
of Managed Care um is that you're only
and insurance is that you're only going
to get reimbursed for things that are
medically necessary and also a covered
benefit so those are and I would just
say over the years we have Revis visited
the
statute yeah so when you get when you
get a claim
denied as medically
unnecessary somebody's somebody's
pushing the envelope here but they
already know that it's it's medically
unnecessary do you understand what I
mean by pushing the envelope it really
depends on the um the circumstances
would it be included in the
circumstances as one
example it could be that you know yeah
generally experimental stuff is excluded
because it's not accepted that that is
going to address the issue so that's a
little bit different but yeah if you're
talking about an in network provider
they should be up to speed on what is
medically necessary or not if there's a
disagreement on that that's where we go
through the appeals and external review
process so what I'm trying to get at
here Mr chairman is if it is if if it's
known what's medically acceptable
then why would somebody put in a claim
for something that's medically
unnecessary unless they're attempting to
shake you know rattle the cage yeah but
medically unnecessary was very low right
wasn't that a low number well well it is
but still no it's just it it very rarely
that
happens well let me tell you what I
know okay okay we each each health
insurance entity has a medical
director yep okay and the medical
director's responsibility is to know
what the uh standard standards of
practice the protocols that know know
what is expected now one of the things
we used to joke about in the committee
is we used to call it the cookbook
because he would say okay for the first
time you do this and then if that didn't
work then you do this and then you do
this you keep turning the page you know
in the cookbook but that at the end of
the day everything thing is um is in
terms of the standard of practice is
what this is what everybody has agreed
is the pro appropriate step next
step and but that can change and then if
you take the example the DSM which is
the mental health I mean that we're up
to like 14 now and when I first got
started we were like four right and so
you know that so yes these things do
change well well I understand that this
is a dynamic
process because because we don't have
settled science on
everything learning has become quite
popular these days that's why we call it
practicing medic not mastering it
medically necessary is is this where
commissioner vet Court's remarks with
respect to people making
mistakes why would you why would you put
in a claim that you otherwise know is
not medically necessary and it therefore
becomes part of the0
65% so I mean again there is a whole
spectrum of reasons why medical
necessity can go Ary but one of them
could be that you know to treat
condition
a you know there are you know these
different treatments available and the
one that
you did you know is the most appropriate
if the patient exhibits with you know
these three symptoms and it could be in
this instance the treatment was provided
but for this patient they only had two
of those symptoms and not all three so
maybe was isn't the best so it could be
you know things like that there's
different criteria that you know a
patient would have to meet for a certain
condition and it could be that you know
the providers is not as up to speed on
some of those things and the clinical
guidelines can vary by carrier as well
so so in the instance if you if I may so
so so in the case that you've just cited
the example you just cited this is an
adverse consequence yes an adverse
determination well it's an adverse
consequence as well for the for the
insured because the provider made a
mistake by not choosing the appropriate
best
accepted uh course of care yes and in
that instance typically the patient is
held harmless and the provider has to
eat the cost of who decides that that's
part of um in provider
contracts thank you I could Co thank you
thank
you answer some more questions next
piece of legislation I
passed so if we move on to um 12 appeals
so if you have an adverse determination
and your claim is denied there is um
carriers are required to have a
grievance procedures that are appeals
processes and if you look at 420 J5
there's a list of things that it has to
include including time frames who's
going to be reviewing it
um
and one of the things is the claiming
submit written comments documents
records and other information um and all
the information and documents submitted
would be reviewed um by someone who's
different than who made the idential
denial so there's a lot of Protections
in there if that still does not resolve
the issue then if we turn to slide 13
you can go to external review so the
internal appeals process is handled at
the carrier level and even though
there's different people they all are
within that carrier system external
review is going to an independent third
part party and the sides submit their
both both of their arguments about why
something is medically necessary or not
and then this independent review
organization makes that determination
this is binding on the parties and um
there's a lot of statutary requirements
for how the system works as well so if
you looked at 420 j5- a through 420
j5- there's a lot of procedures time
frames that need to be um complied with
and if it's something that needs um an
expedient decision there's like a
72-hour time frame for um submitting
these and getting a
response um and our experience uh recent
experience with this process is that
about 40% of the time the carrier's
decision gets overturned so it's a
meaningful
process yeah and for calendar year 22
there were 46 eligible claims submitted
for external review and the department
handles that submission
process
so if you turn to um the next slide
number
um sometimes claims are adjudicated not
as expected and this kind of falls out
of the realm of prompt pay because the
claim is processed so it's not a
violation of prompt pay but the amount
of payment the provider may get may not
be what they were expecting and it could
be that you know they're looking at the
wrong fee schedule or miscalculated and
thought they were supposed to get more
money when in fact they're not
necessarily entitled to it or it could
be that the carrier is Prov
um processing it using the wrong fee
schedule and are supposed to be paying
more money um it could be that there
are con system configuration issues that
lead to you know wrong fee schedule
wrong amount of co- insurance or
applying a co- insurance instead of
co-payment there's a variety of reasons
why things can go wrong and even though
the claim is processed and there's no
dispute this is a covered benefit there
is some discrepancy see and the numbers
and what is actually getting paid and
what's not so there's a lot of issues
and
that unless you go in and do a claims
examination you're looking at each one
of these individual claims there's no
easy way to figure out what exactly went
wrong
here so that kind of brings us to the
role of the insurance department which
is slide 15 Mr chairman question yes so
are we still within 30 days here or we
on a different clock when we move from
page 12 to 13 to 14 here in the appeals
process there are different timelines so
right associated with appeals and
Grievances and then again with external
review so where are we now what what
kind of a clock applies in the appeals
process part of it depends on when the
um covered person submits the appeal so
I believe they have 180 days to submit
the appeal and then um assuming you know
they have all the right information I
believe they have 30 days to adjudicate
it but I might have to that but if it
was a clean claim so it it just and then
by the time the check gets
cut it's going to be that's going to be
close that's not more than you know the
30 plus days and then it's because it's
it was adjudicated but but now it's the
payment is made and the doctor says oh
this is not what I was
expecting yes and that would that can
happen in a very short period of time
yes I'm still back on the clock if if
you don't mind so 30 days adverse
decision
now uh the provider is
notified now we have 180 days he he or
she they have 180 days to to appeal if
an appeal is filed any time within the
180 days then there's a new clock that
starts on the appeal and that's 30 days
for a decision to be rendered I I
believe somebody I'd have to double
check that it's in the statute all this
is very critical because one of the
issues that we're hearing is that these
things go on and on and on for forever
and and it seems to me that there are
definite time frames here yes and and we
might not be entirely happy with what
they are but it's 30 180 30 yeah so if
you could just keep that in mind as you
go along I'd appreciate it because I'm
trying to keep track of like worst case
scenarios here where okay it went 30
days I got notified well I the person
filed 1879 Days Later well then it was
another 30 days okay thank you yes and a
lot of time too if more information's
needed those clocks stop so it often
times becomes dependent on the person
making filing these appeals filing the
necessary information you know if
they're filing it immediately this whole
process is going to move much quicker
but again if they're waiting to 179th
day to do it then it's going to stretch
out the process longer okay so in sports
terms if we if we might this will be
helpful to me basketball or or football
we can actually have a
timeout
yes yeah so while the carrier is waiting
for them to submit more information once
they say oh we can't do anything yet we
need you to submit this information the
clock stops until they get the
additional information and then the
clock restarts yes so now now it could
be even longer than 180 days yes okay
this is very helpful thank you okay okay
so are we all set on those those issues
okay so slide 15 the role of insurance
department so the insurance department
enforces the insurance laws to protect
consumers and to ensure a stable market
and we do that with our consumer
services our market analysis
investigations
examinations what the department does
not have the jurisdiction or authority
to do is to resolve contractual disputes
between insurers and any entity or
individual that they contract with so
it's important to keep in mind we're
regulating the market we want to make
sure things are um moving in accordance
with law but part of this issue is
contractual disputes between insurers
and the entities they contract with and
we don't have jurisdiction over that so
moving on to the next slide number 16 um
when we're talking about insurance
regulation we like to talk about the
Continuum of insurance regulation and
that's what this is trying to um show
you is that the Continuum gives
Regulators the flexibility to use the
most appropriate amount of Regulation
necessary to address an issue it gives
us um more flexibility to use our
resources in the most efficient way
possible to attain quick results so not
every issue is going to lead to a market
conduct examination because those are
very lengthy timec consuming resource
intensive processes sometimes it's um a
lot quicker and more effective for us to
do light touch which would be on the
contact end of the Spectrum which means
picking up the phone making a phone call
sending a letter something simple like
that to resolve the issue and um so
that's at one end of the spectrum and
then it works up to investigations which
can include documents requests
interrogatories interviews attempting to
um facilitate some type of uh dispute
resolution U between the parties and
then it goes towards examination
examination is a very
detailed extensive process that we'll
get to later and then all of this can
lead to enforcement and on the far right
side of enforcement is the um most harsh
thing we could do which would be to
revoke a license and that would only be
in the most extreme situations would we
revoke a
license so if you turn to slide number
17 um our consumer services unit uh is
one of the tools we use and they help
educate consumers and residents about
insurance products assist residents and
Healthcare Providers navigating the
complexity of the insurance industry and
assist
um other department staff in doing
investigations so for calendar year 22
the consumer services received 313
consumer complaints relating to Health
Products of those 73% related to some
kind of claims issue and of that 73%
only 20% of those complaints were
confirmed as a regulatory
violation we also um our consumer
services also helped
Health Care Providers and we call their
um submissions inquiries as opposed to
complaints which are by consumers and
for calendar year 22 we received 115
healthc care provider inquiries 81% of
those related to some kind of claims
issue and 25% of those were confirmed as
a regulatory violation um and then we
have our consumer services contact
information there if anyone wants to
reach out about um their own specific
complaint or have a constituent that you
would like to direct her way so next
slide number 18 we're on market
analysis market analysis is another part
of the Continuum of Regulation that
consists of collecting and analyzing
data and other information to assist
Regulators in monitoring the market
identifying problems early on and
focusing resources in a way to better
prioritize and coordinate various Market
conduct
functions so if you turn to the next
slide number
19 um next on the is investigations so
our investigation statute is RSA 400
a16 um this gives us very broad
authority to investigate anything under
title 37 which is relating to
Insurance um for calendar year 22 our
Market conduct team had 45 open in
investigations relating to health
insurance of those 73% related to some
kind of claims handling issue
investigations are comp confidential and
we can't disclose any of the information
obtained during an investigation and
that's by Statute and um we can disclose
when we do take a regulatory action so
if you want to look at the Department's
website under Legal Information if you
scroll down towards the bottom there's a
listing of all recent regulatory actions
that we have taken or hearings that are
currently scheduled to take place
soon and finally we're on slide 20 um we
have Market conduct examinations and
again and this is the market conduct
regulation handbook it is a very
thorough um compilation of how to do a
market conduct examination we also have
a statute
4837 that details the process and that
flowchart here kind of details the
different stages of an examination
there's a lot of due process built in to
make sure um carriers have an
opportunity to um weigh in when there
are findings um and it can lead to
there's an examination report um
enforcement actions down the line but it
can be a very lengthy process because
it's very detailed and very resource
intensive and those are privilege and
confidential until regulatory action is
taken as well so while we may be in the
midst of an Market conduct examination
we are unable to disclose any of those
details until there is a final
taken phenomenal job Michelle uh and
thank you Alex as well uh just a few
brief concluding thoughts before we take
any questions that you still may have
you know obviously I hope the
presentation this afternoon has
demonstrated the nature and complexity
of the issue as I uh outlined at the
outset and my belief that
unfortunately I think getting to the
bottom of this situation is well beyond
the scope of
legislation and I know that that is
perhaps disappointing I used to sit in
your seats I completely understand the
strong desire to be able to fix problems
via piece of
legislation unfortunately I think the
the nature of this is outside of that
scope so what is the answer at least in
the short
term the answer is for the appropriate
individuals and decision makers on both
sides both the carrier side and the
provider side to come together with the
full complement of information in the
claims file and work through those
claims and my understanding is is that
that process is currently well underway
that said I appreciate the fact that
that process is slow and our hospitals
in particular I know are frustrated but
as we sit here today at least uh that is
the most effective way to resolve these
issues and to get the providers
appropriately uh paid my commitment to
you and our Department's commitment to
you will be to do do everything that we
can to facilitate those conversations to
provide resources and expertise wherever
and whenever we can and to hold the
insurance carriers accountable those are
the entities that we have regulatory
authority over that is part of our job
but as it pertains to the long-standing
dispute I have made a personal
commitment to do everything that I can
to resolve this issue this issue was
featured prominently last month when my
hearing to be insurance commissioner
took place before the executive Council
and so that is a commitment that I made
to them it is a commitment that I will
make uh to you as well you know I think
again as you hear and see some of these
reports about the current Dynamic I
think that of the slides that we've
provided you with and I think the
material here is incredibly useful to
you I think to understand what's going
on here
it's not prompay it is the issues that
are highlighted here on the slide that
says claim adjudicated not as expected
that is what we believe is at the core
of the
dispute and so again we will work with
both sides to figure out these issues if
there are glitches in the system if
there are systematic problems in the
system we will do everything we can to
work with the parties to identify those
issues too I'll just conclude by saying
that you know I've been asked and I know
the previous commissioner was asked why
not bring forward a market conduct exam
to this issue from my perspective the
answer is fairly simple my goal is to
get the providers paid quickly I am told
and they relay to me and I'm sure
they've relay to you that some of them
are struggling financially and that
these holdups are impacting their
operations I have absolutely no reason
to not believe those claims are
absolutely true so that being the case
the commitment and I think the goal has
to be to move as quickly as we can to
resolve these issues and get them paid
and as I said as grueling as that
process is to sit down and make sure the
claims are clean to make sure that
you've got the interplay between the you
know the the the allowed amount the
charged amount and all of those
different complexities that go into this
thing you know It's a Grind I will admit
but it is
faster than
this so at least for
now um my goal is to try to do not take
the easy way out but to try to do the
thing that is going to be most quick
that's not to say that we wouldn't do an
exam it's a important tool that we have
as Regulators I would never take
important tools off the table for us uh
so it's not to say that we wouldn't at
some point uh I am a a patient man a
fair man my kids might dispute that some
days but I try um I want to see
continued progress and I want to see
that we are on a trajectory to end this
issue and that is going to be my focus
you any
questions so how you when when clearly
there are some cases that just go are
going on too long
how do we create a system where where
forces a conversation about how what's
going on why I mean it's some is there
must be some kind of Drop Dead dat you
know something that say boy we need we
need to get the parties in the room
together and figure out why this case
why this is not paid I mean I don't know
if it's a dollar amount or a time frame
amount or something but it seems to me
that there that there has to be some
some way to you know to when a case has
just been hanging around way too long or
just not been paid there's got to be
some way we can you know say have the
department say intervene and say okay
of so um as I said we don't have
jurisdiction over contractual disputes
between providers and um and carriers
that being said you know the department
is a resource available we have in the
past and we continue to do so help to
try to mediate disputes and get some
common ground from those experiences
it's not that there is one issue that
just needs to be fixed it's not that you
know these claims are not being
processed because of this one thing it's
a variety of issues and a lot of the
time it's that the providers and the
carriers are in a way talking a
different language and they really do
need to just get in the same room and
work through these things and you know
they do have um civil remedies available
because this is a contractual dispute
between the two
parties Mr chairman you're telling
you're the physician should sue the
insurance company I think that's a last
resort I think they should be they'll be
able to work out there
difficulties yes and with regard with
reference to you're not being able to
intervene in terms of in in uh
contractual disputes nevertheless last
with from your Vantage Point are you
seeing any
patterns that are examples of what might
be considered good faith
or um suspicious in nature with respect
to delays and I'm thinking once again
about especially with respect to the
clock questions that I posos you know
the clock can stop at some point during
the 180 days for information I I could
see see that hypothetically as a
stalling tactic if I wanted to take a
kind of a dark view of all of this but I
I'm just not being as involved as you
all are I'm just wondering are there any
points at which you are seeing things
that even though you do not have the
tools to be able to effectuate what the
chairman is asking to to get things
moved along more expeditiously are are
you seeing any patterns of behavior that
are are suspect and
disturbing I have not seen any patterns
along the lines of what you described
and if I had if I was I would assure you
that they would be getting a knock at
the door from our enforcement unit uh as
I said at the beginning what I see here
are people who are trying as best as
they can in good faith to work through
an incredibly complex system I'll give
you an example U Michelle myself Jason
Dexter we personally sat in on I guess
for a lack of a better term you could
call a mediation session between a
carrier and New Hampshire hospital we
felt as though we had a special
obligation to New Hampshire hospital
being that they are a state entity and
given the nature of the work that they
do and to sit down and go through Claim
by claim and understand the little ways
in which these things can go sideways to
Michelle's Point sometimes the
communication breakdowns that happen uh
where one person is referring to this
thing the other person misinterprets
what that thing is and then sometimes
there are just outright staffing issues
I mean I think we all appreciate that
across the state there's turnover
there's there's Staffing challenges that
all come together along with the
complexity of the issues that we've
talked about to cause
delays um you know in sometimes it's a
matter of hey uh we sent you an email
several months ago saying that the only
thing that we needed to properly
adjudicate this claim was an explanation
of benefits and say okay well where did
that email go to well it went to Susan
Jones well Susan Jones left three weeks
ago so we've got to go through that
whole process all over again um as I
said it's it's a damnable misery it
really is and and there there are no
easy solutions here and I appreciate the
frustrations I appreciate the pressure
that the hospitals and the other
providers are facing but I can't I can't
come here and and always give you good
news I can give you the truth which is
what I will always try to do and the
truth is is that the way we continue to
make some progress with this is to go
through this slow and yes long and
arduous process uh but it is going to be
the thing that will ultimately iron out
the issues and then as Michelle said as
we go through this process if we are
starting to identify systematic issues
uh then it opens up another series of
potential tools that we can bring to the
table so Mr chair so um it it's
interesting you use the word uh
systematic or uh because I I I was
thinking about if if this is if if
you're not finding human issues that are
troubling so we're not talking about
mistakes you know this went to Susan
Jones she's not here anymore whatever so
are are you as as you look at the system
do you believe that the system is a good
system and that it doesn't really need
tweaking fixing or overhaul it's not the
system that is the problem it's that we
have people
involved and the people who are feeling
this of course are most uh that we're
hearing from are the small uh providers
and and the uh the patients the policy
holders but it's it's not a system
problem it's the
complexity that's the issue but not the
way in which the system is working it's
the complexity within the system I think
the answer to that is it's it can
sometimes be both I mean it is
consistent that the system is complex
and yes it
disproportionately causes headaches for
the smaller providers who don't have big
back office staffs individuals with
years of experience on how to properly
build uh and how to properly handle
these things yeah it's a it that
complexity is and will always be a real
challenge for them is there an
opportunity to simplify this system I'm
sure that there is that being said you
know uh no system is ever going to be
perfect and humans are not perfect so it
it's not an absolute in terms of the
system though because you raised yeah
but so so I just want to stop you at the
point we you you said can the system be
simplified I'm sure it can be could
could you elaborate on that yeah that
would have to be a negotiation between
the carrier and the provider as to how
but you must have something in mind here
when you say that it's well beyond my
scope no no no no you're saying you
believe that it can be simplified sure
I'm a I'm an internal Optimist I got to
believe there's a better way than what
we're looking at it's rooted in optimism
based on the fact that there are
problems but you can't you you don't
have any model in mind here that that
would be a simpler model no not as I sit
here today all right so I'm getting your
optimism thanks you're getting my
optimism I'll give it's one of the many
services I provide representative Terry
yes
uh but to to further elaborate on your
point though there are times when the
system itself will have an issue and
I'll give you a PR an example the
state's largest Carrier about two years
ago now went through a systems migration
in the process of that systems migration
as is the case in most circumstances by
which you have large systems
migrations things didn't go as smoothly
as was hoped and so that did create a
problem now that problem was identified
they're working to remedy the problem to
um to my knowledge what has been
represented to me is that the most
glaring issues of that migration have
been addressed but of course there is
some residual issues from that that
still have to be resolved so there are
times when the system itself can break
down and and not just be the human
that yeah I would I would not to split
hairs here but I wouldn't consider that
so much the system as the procedures
that are utilized within the system
because you just identified you know the
that a change in the way in which the
provider was was was uh handling these
claims you know we're talking about
software computer software so it's it's
the it's not the process it's the it's
the tools and the mechanisms sure that
that that can create greater problems
right yes okay the distinction that I
was simply trying to make there was
during that that period of time during
that difficult
transition the billing folks could have
done everything exactly as they were
supposed to have done it and it was
out okay okay um before we take action I
I do want to give the
uh
sponsor an opportunity to
so the sponsor well excuse me the
sponsoring Association is the hospital
Association I know you just promoted
me now that you're retired maybe you
house I'm not qualified um so thank you
for the record Paula minan Senior vice
president state government relations for
the New Hampshire Hospital Association
we did ask Senator Susi to sponsor this
bill um and um I appreciate you giving
me the opportunity to speak for a couple
minutes um so and I appreciate very much
all the work um that went into this
presentation and this was I thought
really really well done I I think as and
I won't quote anyone that spoke because
there were a lot of people that spoke
but um it is a very complex system um
and that's why prompt pay I would say
back in I'm trying to remember I was a
representative when this passed probably
back in 2009 um when prompt pay passed
um what we have found and why we asked
this bill to be introduced was because
there you know as laws as as you know
after a while sometimes we need to um
amend laws and that is why we were
trying to address um and I'm not going
to get into specifics about any carrier
but um we put this in for um because our
hospitals you know have to build many
many carriers um and the problem is and
I think rep representative Terry was
kind of getting to this it when the
clock stops and the clock sort of stops
um that's kind of the problem that the
bill the the claim is pended or denied
but when it's pended then you're asking
for additional information and then
nothing happens so that isn't a clean
claim it's it's just sits there it's in
their system it's a pended claim so this
what I was we were attempting to do is
to kind of close that make the clock
start ticking again because it's not
ticking um so so the part that we added
was or to adjudicate the claim within 45
calendar days of receipt of additional
information and then current law is the
claim shall be treated as a clean claim
we added that clock start ticking again
because it's not ticking that's the
problem one of the problems the systems
are very complex um and but they don't
fall within the clean claim definition
so that's what is the problem um because
according to the carriers um what else
did I so yeah pended I think it these
statistics are interesting but another
interesting statistic would be to look
at the overturn overturn rate of the
denials um because we understand that um
that that is just administratively just
adds so much complexity to the system
when you deny
you appeal as Michelle um very
accurately explained how again other
another clock starts ticking but if
you're ultimately going to pay the claim
that would be a very interesting
statistic because that that's just a lot
um and I think the exter I think her def
her um statistic on external review was
interesting too CU that one was um to go
to external review that's pretty in
intense um and for 46 claims 40% of
those were overturned so I think that
that's a really interesting statistic as
well um but to get back to the bill
which um I'm not sure I mean of course
we want this we would like you to pass
this bill we believe there is a need
because again we're trying to address
when they they're just sitting there so
that's what that's why we were
attempting that's what we were
bill um but I'm not at liberty or I
don't think it's appropriate to get into
specifics about um any
particular process going on between
hospitals and carriers um but in general
that is what we always encourage is that
they sit down and work through issue by
issue I would contend and I I think some
of you know but I worked for an
insurance carrier I was provider
relations director for 14 years so what
I would always tell people is go out and
meet with the provider and then let us
know if there are systemic issues I
would contend sometimes there are
systemic issues and we as has been
indicated by the commissioner when you
go through a system um upgrade which
hospitals do um emrs um electronic
medical record when they go through um
those system system upgrades they there
are glitches but we've been dealing with
some glitches with some carriers for
over two years so that is a long time um
so I would contend that there are still
system issues and going through Claim by
claim while it's helpful what really
should be happening is figuring out the
system issues that are the trends that
are coming out of every single claim
that you're reviewing because that is
very time consuming for everyone so I
think that's all I had I'm happy to
answer any questions if I
can
so with respect to my earlier questions
and following up on your remarks we're
there are issues once a I I understand a
claim does not become a clean claim when
there's a problem right
so so a a claim can go into pending
status where presumably more information
is being requested for whatever reasons
correct but that that there is no there
is no clock like there is in basketball
you only get one minute for a timeout
and then you everybody's got to go back
out there and play again there is no
such
clock when when a claim goes into Penny
it could be in there it could it could
be pending indefinitely is that the
issue you're identified and identifying
and you want a time frame assigned to
pending um thank you for your question
so when I think Michelle and corly um
identified when it it's pended and you
request additional information the clock
stops there for the for the carrier
because they're waiting for the pro
provider um unless there's something in
the contract I'm not privy to those
contracts so I wouldn't know but once
what I'm saying is what we have been
told by our hospitals once the
information is requested it's all I mean
there are human beings working on the
computers but it's all electronic of
course so they see what is request Ed
did they forget to provide a medical
record did they need a lab test results
something whatever it is they send
that and then what doesn't happen is
nothing happens on the other end so
there is no clock so that's why I added
we added the words that we did to make
sure that after 45 days once you get the
additional
information once you do something to the
claim process it and if you don't
process process it then then pay it as a
clean
claim so what you're doing is you're
adding specificity in terms of what must
be done within a certain time frame once
certain information is received whereas
now there is no specificity there is no
time clock it could just stay there
forever I've heard that it's not
intentional there's no evidence of
intentionality but let's just call it
benign neglect or you know human error
but what you want to do is tighten this
up and say once the information is
received you have 45 days to make a
determination and then it goes to the
next step and then we got another clock
going on yes yes so do something with it
and if it's whatever happens and like
you said if there's more action that's
needed then that you go to the next step
y
okay thank thank you all right so what
bill
stud right well I mean well the problem
I would have to say Paula is that it's
when you say just pay it okay well what
happens if it wasn't going to get paid I
mean what happens if there and they'll
know within a certain period of time
isn't just about a time period it's not
about a decision it's not about a
specific cir no the bill says pay it pay
it after a certain point of time just
pay it it must be paid regardless that's
that's the way I read
yeah so I'm not sure that this proposed
language is necessary because under the
law it already says that upon the health
carrier's receipt of a requested
information the health car shall
adjudicate the claim within 45 calendar
days so there is already a Time Fair
time period built in there but again
we're saying adjudicate the claim I'm
not exactly sure what the exact language
of this bill says but it would either be
you pay it because it's covered or you
deny it says pay it it says pay it as as
though it was a clean claim right isn't
that what it says
Paula I want to go get it but yeah would
it does say that but it's not happening
so that's what so then treat it as sort
of like because it says if current law
if the required notice is not provided
so if the payer did not send the notice
then the claim shall be treated as a
clean claim so what we added was it
looks like we added that entire bolded
but we didn't so it just we added or to
adjudicate the claim within 40 if they
don't do that sentence above ahead they
don't they don't if they don't do it
then you have to pay it as a clean claim
it I you're right but we're just saying
process it so so that's the teeth in
other words if you don't do this within
45 days then you must pay it as a clean
claim yeah no so there's the penalty
you're
right okay that's one way so because the
language is already that it has to be
done within 4 5 days but it doesn't say
what happens if you don't do it within
45 days and you're saying right well
because the the the law doesn't say what
has to be done after 45 days if 45 days
expires this is what will have to happen
this would be the consequence after 45
days if if they don't do what they're
supposed to do time that's a good way to
describe it just boiling it down so that
we can all understand
this okay okay and so now the question
be so what do we want to do with this is
that true is that true the church is
so if you don't pay or adjudicate the
claim within the time period and it does
get covered there is an interest penalty
so you would have to pay that additional
interest so it to if it took you 60 days
to adjudicate your and you had to
request additional information you would
have to pay that interest for that
additional 15 days do you get involved
after 45 days if as not necessarily
because then it goes back to you know in
the midst of a claims exam if that 7% if
7% are handled um right if the error
rate is less than 7% where pres the
presumption is that they're being
handled appropriately if it's greater
than 7% then there's a presumption that
they're not being handled in accordance
with law we never presume that there's
100% compliance but that's why that
interest is built in so if they're
unable to adjudicate that claim within
the time period they do have to pay
interest as well well who decides when
the interest in the payment have to be
made if it's past that time the carrier
should be um adding that interest in and
okay my understanding they usually do in
the context of an examination we would
go in and say if this was not paid
within that time frame was interest paid
as well and that would be one of the
things we would be looking at in
examination so iation so if I didn't
want to pay this and in 45 days expired
now I have a certain rate of interest
what is it market rate I mean um I would
have to anyway so so now we have
interest that is is being added onto the
claim but now what why would I pay it
this I mean hypothetically this is just
this could go on forever yeah and this
is where Market regulation comes who's
going to make somebody do something the
department would step in in those types
of cases and if this situation were to
come up we would hope that the provider
would file an inquiry with the
Department in our consumer services we
would take a look at it and we would you
know probably tell the carrier why
aren't you paying so so effectively is
there a problem here you know so the so
so the department gets involved here in
and basically leans on them that's what
happens one of the tools you can't make
them pay but if they continue to resist
paying and the interest charges are
going up like you know the meter on the
taxi you can lean on them and in other
words it doesn't look good for them if
they don't eventually process this yes
and just to clarify we cannot not
require payment right that's but we can
if they are not following the law we can
sanction them for not following the
law and and and so you you might be
looking for a way in which they're not
following the law because other
than would that would not following the
law mean that they didn't they didn't
act in good faith within the 45 days yes
if they you could make that
determination yes if they were acting in
bad Fai so you already have this
yes so we don't really need this
bill not do you take a position do you
take a position on this I don't believe
we have no we have not is it because you
haven't taken a position or that you
don't you don't choose to take a
position you know I was not around when
this don't ask her she she's only this
is only her first year in the job how
many no I've been here for four years I
was on maternity leave in the last oh
okay okay concerned with the way it was
drafted and these issues that come out
okay well here's the question I if go if
I follow this
conversation that theoretically at the
end of the day that their interest is
paid um and that's theoretically the
penalty but but um it it is
clearly the insurance company is not is
violating the
statute okay
and the issue then is at that point is
um that when there's a violation of a
statute that we have the the Draconian
opportunity for the Department to pull
their license from for doing business
because they keep uh systematically
violating a statute so maybe what we
should do is have some kind of have uh
and I guess the way to do this right it
would be the uh the the
provider because in this case they're
they're the they're the constituent
who's being harmed by these insurance
companies that on on that the uh
providers uh should notify the
department of of uh this violation and
so at that point you you will now can
start your collecting information about
how often this insurance company is
violating the that default yeah we do
that and actually at a certain point we
um took on that responsibility of
separately taking complaints from Health
Care Providers okay so but but so
Paula if if if we put into the
statute that that
uh sorry we only have one mic maybe we
maybe we can have you guys opposite mics
here but um maybe we should
have uh that you you
the you uh the provider would have a
form to notify the department that you
here here we go again you got another
one where they have paid on a timely
fashion Mr chair why do we need to La I
can just issue a
bulletin uh this is not a bulletin
material it's not bulletin material not
we do appreciate that the department has
now started collecting provider um
concerns and there is um I think they're
seeing more more of interaction um it's
always been consumers and I think it was
kind of a not I I'm not going to say it
was assumed but of course providers are
consumers too but it was really we
always interpreted it it was really more
a patient complaint um so now I think
they've made it very explicit it's right
on their website so I think that that is
help very helpful um and I that may be
another route that um I believe that is
a route that the provider are are
utilizing I just I was trying to text a
colleague to to find out um I have not
um back in the day um many years ago
when I was doing a different job at the
association my understanding and I don't
know if this is still the case it's not
an automatic the penal that that
interest penalty does not automatically
get applied to a paid claim the provider
would have to basically submit a submit
a a bill if you will um that has been at
least some of the experience our members
have had but I do not know that that is
actually what happens now I have I'm
trying to find out but it doesn't
automatically happen necessarily um okay
but you guys think it does right you
think that insurance that that interest
is supposed to be paid right away uh the
law requires it that it automatically be
added in but I think what Paul is saying
is that doesn't always happen that that
is one of the things the insurance
company says well that's nice well you
know where's the bill right the interest
and when we do these Deep dive you know
Market conduct exam looking at claims
that's one of the things we look at was
interest paid after 45 days okay all
right so I I I'm I'm here's here's what
I'm
thinking right who calculates to
7% exactly how Howes how does this
paperwork work so the insurance an him
you you guys always pay that interest on
time why don't you come over sit but and
here come on
down here Saina yes you need to come up
here yes from Anthem I talked to our um
legal counsel earlier and was verifying
that interest actually we have a system
it automatically attaches and I believe
the same as true for Signa and Harvard
Pilgrim as well so we have a great
interest in paying claims on time I just
want to to put that out there so the
providers uh add in the 7% after 45 days
if they haven't paid the claim on our
end it automatically you automatically
begin the clock
begins our system automatically attaches
the required
interest is that are you doing that
voluntarily or because follow to follow
the law follow well the law is
instructing you to do that the
department tells you you have to do that
I believe that's correct if they telling
us we are doing it but I believe it's
correct that we were being told that is
how to make sure we follow the law
okay does that interest get added to the
minimum minimum loss ratio is that
cost that's a good question well the
reason I asked that is not withstanding
that I hate to think this is the reason
why we are premiums are going up but is
that is this a way for us to be able to
track
how bad these payments are whether
things you know whether these late
payments problem is really occurring is
that if you have to know that the
department don't you guys need to know
whether that money's where where that
interest is coming from you know how
that's build and whether it's part of
the minimum and because if you don't
know and I would say it's being thrown
in the minimum loss ratio and that's
that
okay we will schedule this bill
again okay on November 7th and I would
like to hear a way in
which instead of instead of passing what
I consider this Draconian bill which
says just pay it as though it's was a
clean claim that I would like to see uh
a system in place or something some
propos way we could track it and so that
you guys really do know how much of a
problem it is out there and that these
things are not getting
paid and and and I say I would look at
where that money is coming getting build
and how it's getting built and how how
you guys see it because I sure hope it's
not going into my minimum loss ratio
number
right I will look into that too I I I'm
fairly certain it does not it is a
penalty for the so therefore when it
when that reported to the to the
department as in terms of your loss it's
got to be segmented off right it's got
separation yeah I knew there was going
ratio okay does everybody know what I'm
talking about yes our financial analysis
team um does
do consistent review of these issues and
Money Matters and they're constantly
reviewing a lot of financial information
every quarter so I can follow up with
them and find out exactly how penalties
work into the medical loss ratio but be
assured that our financial team is on it
we are monitoring all the financials and
if we saw something concerning in the
financials that were to indicate um an
improper business practice um that would
be one of the things that could trigger
a market cont cond investigation or
examination okay yes I just have a quick
question I guess I i' posst it to to
Paula um we're talking about these
numbers and the penalties etc etc but
aren't there people at the at the end of
at end of the day people who are who
don't get a claim who are who are may be
in real serious financial hardship
because of claim was
denied I'm sorry are we talking about
the providers or yeah these are
hospitals or all providers okay so the
patient is not patient is not patient is
not no as um Michelle said there are
contractual well okay this a contract so
if you're an in network provider you
cannot you cannot balance Bill the
patient right uh so thank you uh if you
would just reiterate or or correct me on
what I believe I heard a few minutes ago
the department is provid information or
given information to providers that
reminds them shall we say of their
obligation to try to collect from the
insurance
company uh rather than to more quickly
default to going after the patient and
is in did I hear you say they don't have
anything greater frequency that that
that that that the providers are are
trying to be more conscientious and
aggressive about following up on claims
that have been filed with the insurance
carrier because we all know as
patients there's that that statement
that we all sign without reading that
says that ultimately we will pay if the
provider doesn't pay uh excuse me the
insurance company doesn't pay and it
would seem to me that that that would be
an easy out for a provider who says I
just don't want to be involved with this
gigantic bureaucracy any longer I'm just
going to go after and therefore then it
come then it does come back on the
policy holder and the patient who now is
is is build for you know maybe hundreds
or thousands of
dollars it's for
that form that we sign is if it's a
non-covered service you can't build if
you have a contractual relationship with
a carrier in that contractual
relationship it in that contract it does
say that you will not balance Bill a
patient so no it's it's more for
something that is not covered
ultimately if we um if the insurance is
not you know El if there's not eligible
or whatever um if the insurance ran out
if it was the wrong you know whatever um
or just not a covered service that's
what that is yeah
yeah okay okay so you'll you guys will
help us out so we
can so we can not have to pass this bill
but we need some way to you know make
sure you're being notified that a if a
carrier is
is laps and getting these things done in
a timely
fashion
great okay with that we're
done
no uh no we're no we're going to meet
again
have uh at this point we're going to
have another subcommittee on this bill
we have another submit on this bill on
on on the 5th on sth seven the 7th okay
that